Secondary,
the Joe Rogan experience my day,
Joe Rogan podcast by day.
Ryan Parsons,
my friend.
Good to see you,
brother.
I'm doing well.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being on man out there.
Kicking ass,
managing fighters,
getting numb,
the cutting edge of science and training
and nutrition and every time I talked to
you got some new cutting edge type shit.
What it's about,
right?
Yeah.
Today it's an improvement to today.
Ryan came in with these new gloves,
these a radius,
mma gloves that literally you can punch
a wall with these things on and they
don't hurt your hands.
I've never experienced anything like
that.
It's really interesting.
So there's like this red.
That's what this is,
this red hard,
high density foam or closed cell foam.
Now there's three sides of it,
but it started years ago,
a fighter who had a boxers knuckle that
was so swollen,
inflamed.
If you just tapped it,
it would be painful for them.
So for a year it affected everything
that we did.
He couldn't hit mid sparring and every
little bit and we wrapped it with tape,
with gauze,
sponges,
everything we could do to try to figure
out how to take the pain away because if
you're going to fight,
you have to punch and it continues to
get irritated.
But I failed and we didn't come up with
any solution.
And that was the end of it.
Fast forward a couple years,
pet cummings durkin developed the exact
same,
huge swollen middle knuckle and there's
a handrail at the UFC,
a cut man,
Rudy.
And he had a different approach to
wrapping hands and he would place the
underneath the knuckle,
not on top pads.
The knuckle like this,
you can't really padded enough.
So if,
uh,
if you're punching with the knuckle,
it stresses the bones in your hand or
your wrist and sometimes your elbow.
So he explained that it was,
had the boxing,
the handgrip guys in the sixties and
seventies in boxing used to wrap where
you put the,
the,
um,
the pad on the bottom of the knuckles.
And if you put your fingers like this,
there's a natural flex that's involved
with your hands and it saves punching
here and decreases the stress here.
So instead of putting it over the Naco,
if you're like looking at a fist coming
your way,
you would put it below.
So for folks who are just listening to
this,
you would just put it below the bumps of
the knuckle,
the brush where the bone sticks out.
Correct.
And this,
is this something you developed
yourself?
I watched him do that now here,
take this.
And I was reaching for his thing and I'm
knocked over my coffee.
I've done this a hundred times on a
show.
That's all right.
No electronics were damaged.
So yeah.
So anyways,
the,
I kinda saw that he was doing with the
guys and we played around with it and
the experience with um,
the fighter a few years ago.
And then with pat it was something that
was really affecting our day to day
life.
So we kind of took that concept and
expanded upon it and we tested so many
different styles of foam shapes,
densities,
and we ended up with this and I made a
prototype at home and pat started using.
We'd walk around my kitchen with their
hands wrapped,
punching the granite countertops and no
boy,
there's something here,
I don't know what it is,
but this really works.
And Pat started to use them in training.
I didn't pay attention for a couple
weeks and I saw that every day he was
washing the same handwriting.
I said,
should we get you some new handed
because none of the other ones don't
work.
This is the one I like.
And that kind of was our little light
bulb moment right there.
It said,
we've got to figure out what's going on
here.
So what are those?
When a boxer gets that knuckle,
like boxers,
Michael,
what is that?
It's just a terribly irritated.
The tendon,
when the attending can get torn,
all the soft tissues around it,
the joint capsule gets what's swelled up
and your knuckle hurts your whole hand
or to decrease his grip strength.
So especially in Emma,
where grips so important,
all of a sudden now you can't squeeze
like you can.
You're grappling goes mean.
There's really longterm implications of
that and a lot of times these are
problems that plague fighters for years.
What do you think about this idea?
I've been throwing this around a lot
lately.
I think that it might be better for
everybody if there was no gloves.
Well you'll have less knockouts,
less knockout.
It was brain damage.
You have less hand damage,
I might say.
You have more hand damaging.
So yeah,
for sure.
Because gloves protect,
right?
So you'll have,
you'll have less brain damage,
less gets initially,
right?
But wouldn't everybody like sort of
figure out what you can and can't get
away with when it comes to punching?
You can't just fucking whale away.
You have to be more precise in your,
your implementation of strikes.
I guess in theory that's true.
But you get in the middle of a fight and
this happens all the time and training
paths.
Boxers,
knuckled didn't come initially from
hitting,
hitting pads.
It came from an Emma mma glove and he
came into scramble situation,
hit someone in the head,
the heart part of their head and his
knuckles swelled up,
so you're going to get in the scramble
situations,
especially in Emma,
Emma,
that you're going to catch someone
funny,
but don't you think that maybe there
will be less leg breaks like we're
seeing with like Anderson Silva and
tyrone spong if they were Shin pads for
sure,
and we have more protection is going to
be more protection.
There's going to be less injuries with
that,
but you have,
but no one's going to accept that.
Right?
You can't go back.
No one's going to say like,
you know,
if you start patting people shinzen,
people are going to go,
come on.
What are we doing visually?
The fans are gonna,
hate it,
and also padding your shins or some
trouble with grappling with that.
It's hard to grapple with with
shinguards,
which brings me back to the gloves.
It's hard to sink in.
Chokes.
It's hard to think in chokes those
gloves like rear nakeds and things along
those lines.
It's hard to for sure,
to lock up the correct hand position.
Teens are tougher to get.
There's a bunch of things that are
tougher to secure your hand.
Your hand grips true.
It's a tradeoff.
Nana maybe right?
There's a constant we give and take in
this sport,
but it seems to me that
if you can hit someone with a raw elbow,
Rodney Roshan Rauf foot raw heal,
you can heal someone in the head Aka,
you know,
ah,
Edson Barboza,
Terry Adam,
which is one of the worst knockouts
ever.
Uh,
we'll kick to the head the amount of
fucking force you generate.
It's just insane.
But no,
no padding at all.
I mean,
literally these pads are protecting the
hand more than they're protecting the
fighter from damage,
right?
Sure.
For sure.
Right?
Definitely.
So if that's the case,
he's not like a,
an almost like an a crutch for the
striker,
for the,
for the person who's actually delivering
the shots,
you're giving them an unfair advantage.
You're taping the wrist top and an
unnatural way because it's part of
punching things.
Your risk buckle,
like you have to learn how to punch
correctly.
And you have to be much more diligent
about the placement of your punches
because when you hit things,
if you've ever seen like a slow motion
video of someone hitting something with
a bare knuckle,
your fucking risk just gives our Nah,
it's a joint.
It's hard to keep stiff,
you know?
And I think,
I think we have an unrealistic
perception of striking because of the
fact that guys wear gloves and tape
wraps and all that jazz.
I think it's unrealistic.
It definitely changes things for sure.
Yeah.
I think.
I think there could be an argument for
it and I think it would probably save a
lot of shots that guys eat.
You know,
I think the overall,
like over the course of your career,
I think it would be significantly less
impacts,
but a lot of that cumulative traumas is
training based to.
Yeah.
So these,
we,
we knew they worked and so we teamed up
with a sport science lab at Uc Fullerton
and got a real phd pumping out real
research and said,
listen,
we can punch our granite countertops
with these.
Tell us if we're imagining this or it
really works.
So he did a,
the first of a series of,
of uh,
academic studies on,
on this approach to it,
and found a couple of things that they
reduce impact dramatically.
And the white,
one of the ways they first tested it,
they took a,
an 18 to 35 and 50 pound Kettlebell and
they did a rap on the Kettlebell with
this approach.
And then drop it.
We bought this special,
it's called a strike,
make pet measures impact forces.
And it was scientifically calibrates.
We know,
okay,
this thing works.
And they did repeated thousands of drops
on this and they measured it and it was
like,
I can't give the number and tell for
some reason until this study is
published.
But it was a tremendous decrease.
Even with a 50 pound Kettlebell,
it decreased the force of that
Kettlebell onto the pad.
So the issue with brain trauma is not
just the impact,
but the amount that it forces the head
back,
right?
The snap of the head.
That's an issue of it to you.
You get here,
your brain slams into the back of your
head and then comes back again.
Do you think that that would be reduced?
I don't that.
I don't think it's going to change,
but you're going to have more
absorption,
so you have to look at a couple of
things.
It's the basic physics equation.
The force of something equals the mass.
How big it is times acceleration,
how
fast it's moving this way is a couple of
grams,
so it doesn't increase the mass at all.
Right there.
You have a big thick pad,
but it's still four ounces.
Just like an MMA glove that you compete,
I think.
Uh,
yeah.
I think our gloves way,
4.5
ounces,
these wraps,
they're very standard hundred daily and
traps as well.
Um,
but the pad itself doesn't mean you can
feel it doesn't play anything.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
This is like,
they keep coming up with new material in
or new ways to formulate material that
makes for things like this.
This is fascinating to me.
That's a closed cell foam.
So there's,
I mean you can put it in the Washer and
dryer,
it doesn't get.
Yeah,
bacteria can't grow anything like that.
So w we tested it and we also found that
it reduces,
if you punch being you're wearing that,
it's less forced to my brain as well.
And the reason why that is another
equation,
you have to look at it as the pressure.
So if you throw a punch and a slap,
the force is exactly the same.
If it's the same arc and the same
strike.
The difference why it punches more
devastating is because that,
that force is condensed into a smaller
area,
on a punch with a slap.
It's spread out over a wider area.
So if you could fish slapped by someone
with a little hand,
it probably hurts more.
Now I'm going to assume that fucking
room,
that's why it hurts more when girls
bitch slap you because it hurts your
pride to.
There you go.
So this,
this approach,
um,
do you think that this is.
The problem with it in competition is
they're too,
they're too big.
It's a train in glove competitions,
all different.
But most people don't compete,
but these are not that much bigger than
the ones that were in pride.
Like the problems are pretty good at
all.
That it also makes it more difficult to
extend your fingers.
So we'll help with ipos.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's a big one man.
And that was another thing that pride to
dress better than the UFC because it was
very rarely were there.
I pokes and pride.
I've been really kind of studying this I
poke thing a lot over the past few
years.
It's that,
you know,
that old cliche,
the definition of insanity is doing
something over and over again the exact
same way.
Hoping for different result.
That's sort of what we're doing with
this ipad thing.
Yeah,
I mean every goddamn fight there's like,
look at the last Aldo Mendez fight was
like two,
at least two ipos right there where they
stop the action back off.
Like that's crazy that,
that to me it's crazy that you're high
level competition guys.
Not Cheating,
it's just they're just doing what
happens in a fight normally in guys are
getting poked in the eye.
I mean,
how many more guys have to get like a
Michael Bisping type injury where
Michael Bisping has one crazy fucking
lie.
He trains with us now.
Does he?
Yeah,
he's high.
That one eye is not good.
Yeah.
Doesn't seem to affect them in train,
but it looks a little funny.
He's a fucking animal.
Michael Bisping is just.
I have say,
I have never met anyone who wants to win
more than Michael Bisping.
He's a fucking animal.
He wants to win every training session.
Every go,
every situation.
That guy is a winner.
He's a fucking animal and he doesn't
have like a extreme athletic talent or
extreme physical gifts.
It's just cardiovascular training.
Discipline will toughness.
He's got all these other things,
but like you look at a guy like Jon
Jones,
just incredible physical talent.
You know,
you look at a guy like I'm Hector
Lombard,
ridiculous physical talent on top of the
discipline,
all that stuff.
Bisbing just a normal guy,
a normal guy who's tough as shit.
Tough as shit.
He doesn't get enough credit.
I really don't think he gets nearly
enough credit.
The guys,
these last two have been very juice hop,
top high level guy.
Well,
I mean I'd probably.
Tim Kennedy.
Yeah.
Tim Kennedy was a clean,
clean as a whistle,
but everybody else essentially was on
something that you can't do anymore.
I don't know.
What I like about him is grit and
they've found that grit is a much better
predictor of success than I queue is,
so when you find someone who really
wants something and they're willing to
suffer and keep going and fail and get
up again and fail and get up again,
that's the guy that you got to put your
money on visiting does that better than
anyone.
He certainly does,
but it him against a guy like Anderson
Silva and his prime.
You know that,
that that's like this crossover,
this like we're the land of grit meets
extreme talent and confidence and just
that rare quality that the goats possess
the greatest of all times.
Guys that,
that rare thing that Anderson had for a
few years in his prime.
It seems like Weidman's kind of stolen
that from him pretty.
Which is a shame too,
because he was so dominant for so long.
No shame.
Beautiful.
It's the way.
I don't mean that.
I mean if,
if people don't think as highly of
Anderson Silva because he lost and that
would be a shame.
I don't see that.
It's just,
you know,
Weidman was the right guy at the right
time.
And that's the beautiful thing about the
sport.
It's,
you know,
new guys come along and then Weidman
becomes that guy and Weidman,
you know,
he'd beat Leo.
Machida,
he's,
he's a fucking savage man at
[inaudible].
That guy's a tank.
He just a goddamn iron willed steel
jawed knockout machine.
That's a fucking high caliber for time.
Division One,
all American wrestler that wants to
steal your soul once again on top of you
and punch through your fucking your bone
structure until he get out your soul.
Just Yank it out of your body.
And when.
And there's always going to be those
guys,
you know,
like a nature documentary that the big
male lion at some point is driven off
of.
Someone new comes along.
It's going to happen.
You know,
Anderson's 39 now and he just signed a
15 fight deal.
Yeah.
How crazy is he at 39?
He's like,
just for fun.
I don't know,
maybe he's going to do all 15 fights.
I mean he would have to do,
but it's.
So Ronnie probably fights the most of
anybody,
right?
Probably fights about five times a year.
I think.
Neil magnifique six times last year.
Did he really?
Yeah.
Neil's I started was trying to fight a
six time.
Maybe you're right.
So let's say six times.
Probably the most.
That's pretty extreme.
Every two months.
That's the most anybody does,
right?
Pretty much for a headliner there.
You gotta figure it's every year,
maybe three times a year if you're
really lucky.
So if he.
Yeah,
that's true.
Right?
Because you've got to sell it.
It's not only magnesium.
The undercard is like,
people look forward to seeing them fight
good fighter,
but it's not like people are like
shelling out pay per view dollars to see
a guy who's relatively unknown except
regards hardcore guys like you or me who
really know about it,
but a guy like Anderson selling pay per
view,
selling cards,
headline Fox,
he probably can't fight but three times
a year Max realty especially talking
about age and then preparation.
It's going to take him three months to
prepare because that's how he's used to
been doing.
If you're young and you're just getting
started,
you can go fight more,
but once you get older you kind of need
that time and then you've had that
experience of longer fight camps and
better preparation and so what do you
think the 15 fight deal just to keep
them from going to bell door.
I would imagine that was on Anderson's
end.
I don't know,
but I wonder because he had a deal and
then when they were back in Rio for this
past UFC,
although Mendez fight,
they resigned them.
They throw out the old deal,
resigned them to 15 fight deal.
He's done everything there is to deal
helping assist with I.
He's one of the greatest ever.
He was the greatest ever,
I think for sure,
but the argument can be made,
especially now that he's lost.
The argument can be made for fader.
Those the only two guys I think that
fall into the greatest ever faders tough
thing is he never fought in the UFC.
That's,
that's the one strike against them.
Also,
the way he lost two big foot and the way
he lost his doom.
It's like an Henderson Henderson.
Yeah,
that's a big one too,
man.
He was kind of a different guy by that
time though,
you know,
I think you'd already sort of checked
out.
His body looked way different,
like go back and watch the Food G to
fight.
When he fought Fujita,
who's fucking rocked?
It was swole.
He still had that big Russian beer
belly,
but he was swole.
He was a big thick.
We shared locker rooms with him and
pride before.
Oh really?
Yeah.
How does he prepare?
What does he want?
What's his warm up like?
They're always pretty mellow.
I have watched the warm up with him.
We were always,
for whatever reason,
it didn't turn out like that,
but sometimes you pay attention to the
warm up.
Sometimes you'd done just depends where
you fall in the card.
One of the things that I really love
about BMA is that there's guys like you
that are out there that really aren't
almost forced to innovate.
Yeah.
It's like,
this is not a sport like football or
basketball where there's established
training protocols and everybody sort of
knows the exact right way to go about
doing things.
No,
it's like guys like you who are going,
oh,
what if there was no training protocols,
so they had to be started.
Some someone,
I think they thought they were insulted
me when it said Ryan is always trying to
make everything better.
Exactly.
That's exactly it.
That's the greatest compliment.
You're in.
Salt was a great compliment.
When people think that for some reason
everything's fine.
He just work hard.
Everything is fine,
but no,
there's,
there's all sorts of ways to do things
the right way.
Will w I wrote the first team quest
training manual 14 years ago,
so it's been a long time thinking about
the progress and how you train for
sports now,
there's been an evolution of the
technical side of things.
In the beginning technique you had to
know the technique.
If you had never seen an arm bar before
or didn't hide to a double leg,
the what became very important.
What W,
W,
what techniques do I feel?
How do you defend this?
If you don't know,
then all of a sudden,
you know,
I met Art Jimson the other day.
I met rob.
I met art at one of the recent UFC.
He seemed with his glove.
He brought that one.
He gave me a glove and that's really
nice guy,
but he just had never even seen.
If you don't know that that can exist,
you have to figure out the what now,
the what is everywhere.
I can have Marcella Garcia teach me how
to choke someone on Youtube in two
minutes and does this cost me any money?
Right?
Right.
If I want,
I can save up a little bit of money.
I can go to New York and I can probably
do a private with him for,
I don't know,
couple hundred bucks or something like
that.
Whatever it is,
whatever it is,
you know,
and there's so many people,
there's so many people who can teach me
how to have a box,
how to kickbox everything.
So the what isn't important anymore.
Now it's why.
Why are you doing what you're doing?
So that's what I spend most of my
timeline.
We've changed the nature of how we
structure training camps and nature of
how we train for each fight has to
adjust and change a little bit because
every fight is different.
You know where the what is still sort of
like ambiguous or missing is in
traditional karate techniques or
traditional taekwondo techniques.
Like a lot of people are doing a lot of
those wrong.
Still like high level guys still throw
bad spinning back ticks.
They still throw bad.
We'll kicks like high level guys,
but then some guys pick it up while
you're [inaudible] fucking 37 years old.
All of a sudden he's got a we'll kick
out of nowhere.
We fight rockhold.
He hits him in the head with a we'll
kick.
It's never even fucking thrown a.
we'll check before he throws one.
We'll kick earlier in that round misses
and then throws the second one,
clocks rockhold and finishes them off
from the ground like what the fuck.
And you know where a lot of detours
kicking is coming from brittle hands.
You a lot of his kickings coming from VV
tours had more than seven surgeries on
his hands.
He's always breaking his hands.
So he started to.
He's like forced himself.
Like when he fought Jon Jones,
he had a fucked up hand going into that
fight.
You know,
I,
I'd spoken with him in Brazil just maybe
a few months before that and he had a
pin in his hand.
So a few months before fighting for the
light heavyweight title against arguably
the greatest light heavyweight ever.
He's got a fucking broken hand,
you know,
so he started developing his kicks a lot
more and that's where you started
knocked out being with a head kick
fucked up.
Henderson with the head kicks,
head kicks were not a part of his
repertoire in the early days.
It was all wide stance.
Stand your ground floor blitzkrieg with
those boxing punches.
He's forced to adapt and forced to for
forced to learn and grow.
But when it comes to like across the
board,
if you got,
if we took everybody in the UFC roster,
a 400 plus guys,
whatever it is,
and we brought him into the room and I
said,
show me how you'd throw a spinning back
kick,
show me how you throw.
We'll kick.
1% of them would be doing it right.
Maybe,
maybe 1%.
Show me how to throw a right hand.
Hundred percent would do it right.
Show me how to throw a left hook.
Just two variations.
They would all be doing it right.
You know,
either it's not hand,
you know,
a knuckles up or knuckles,
uh,
across either one is fine.
Both of them are effective,
but there's a lot of techniques that are
still missing.
There's a lot because flexibility,
dexterity with the legs and having those
abilities.
I think that's the next level.
Shit.
And you're seeing guys like conor
mcgregor who's coming along who throws
all these wild kicking techniques that a
lot of guys just don't.
They just don't have in their
repertoire.
They're straight Moy Tai.
But if you've got the Moitai end that I
think that's next level.
There's always room to improve,
right?
Yeah.
And were forever.
They will be.
For me,
the biggest area of improvement that
people haven't really caught onto is the
cage yet using the cage really using the
cage because the dynamics of fighting on
a cage are totally different.
And I would say over the past four years
we've had this kind of group around
rain.
Pat was there,
I was there,
Mark Munoz,
Bob Ballou contributed a little bit.
Dan Henderson contribute a little bit
like this,
this whole approach,
a systematic approach to fight in the
cage.
Kind of came out through this whole
development process is really
interesting and fun to be a part of.
But that's an area that I see a lot of
guys just still not.
Here's the basic thing I have.
I watched fights with the notebook,
right?
So every time I have new drills that
come out of every every card that I
watch,
and I noticed that when someone tries to
shoot a double leg,
the first thing you do is you turn
right,
you turn your hips.
So your feet are now parallel to the
cage.
Mm hmm.
I would watch probably 200 fights.
I saw one person finished a double leg
when their feet had turned to a parallel
position to the cage.
Guys would still hang on to it.
They'd get their head pushed down.
Maybe they get elbowed in that position.
I'm Travis Browne,
Travis Browne.
Yeah.
They hang onto this double when he's
turned.
If you now know visually,
if you know anything you think about,
you're in a fight.
Adrenaline's going,
you're in your double leg and you look
down,
you're looking at a guy's feet.
If at that point you see,
oh,
they're not pointing straight out.
I have no double way.
You can switch to your single shift.
That one little thing right there.
All of a sudden you can teach somebody
because one of the first things I have
to do is I have to help someone
understand,
number one,
their part in the overall scheme,
how they fit into the culture and the
current state of Emma,
but also how they deal with every
position in the cage and when they go in
there,
I want them to know that they have a
system for approaching each of those,
so by breaking it down and
understanding,
okay,
those,
that one little thing,
if their feet are here,
you have a double leg,
the feeder here,
you have a single leg.
It's a very easy for them for them to
grow on.
Well,
that's something that people that don't
really understand Ma and they just sort
of watching a fight.
I don't think they truly appreciate how
much thinking involved and how much
technique and how much it really is this
massive,
complex,
nuanced game of strategy.
It's about brute force.
It's about kinetic energy.
It's about endurance and will and grit,
but it's also about all those things
applied through discipline and
technique.
It's about positioning and understanding
of knowledge and like this calculated
approach to training and like really
going over every single detail of every
single position.
The challenge comes when you take a guy
and okay,
you're.
Let's say you naturally are a good
wrestler.
He wrestled in college.
You have a long torso and short legs and
you'd have to then kind of start
steering someone in a direction because
the the inherent problem with training
and I'm going to say is that there's too
much.
I can't lift weights enough.
I can't do enough cardio.
I can't do enough to get so I can't box.
I can see you have to go and down,
okay,
we're going to not do all of this stuff
and we're going to know that we're not
going to do it because we don't have
time to wait.
This is where our focus needs to be and
that's the why part of it.
Why are we doing what we're doing?
How do you choose that?
And then it changes based on the person,
based on injuries,
based on age,
based on opponent,
future opponents,
kind of where you see the trajectory of
their career going,
all this.
You have to be thinking about this stuff
in the process.
Yeah.
And it seems like that's one of the
things when they always say styles make
fights.
That's where it really comes into play
because you truly can't be the master of
everything.
Impossible.
Look,
Anderson Silva,
he had a wrestling match.
Chael Sonnen,
Chael sonnen would beat him every
goddamn day of the week.
They'd show up for a year.
Every God damn time they wrestled.
Channel double them,
take them down.
He would.
He would beat him one points every
fucking time.
But it's am amazing at wrestling,
you know.
And so some guys you,
you can get away with doing that.
Some guys you could take down,
you can ground them out.
Some guys,
they figured out how to stand up.
They figure out how to move away from
you.
And some guys they can take you down.
I mean there's a guy like Chael Sonnen
who's gonna run into this.
Who is this Olympic savage has been
training with um,
Dan Henderson or with Daniel cormier and
he's got a couple World Battles Cup
Olympic medals.
Yeah.
That guy,
if you got in there with Shell,
Shell might find himself on his back and
they might be like,
Oh,
good for her though,
right?
Because you'll see guys wrestling and
the cage is very different.
Like if times in wrestling that you
would never attack a single leg and then
go around the waist.
Right?
Except if you're on the cage and then
that's the best way to approach.
Right?
Right.
And also dependent.
You have a guy like a Yoel Romero,
right.
Stud.
Awesome.
His,
his hasn't seen a,
showed a whole lot of wrestling in his
fights.
Gets a couple takedowns here.
But tomorrow's he ragdolled tavares who
was throwing them around like a pillow.
But you look at some of these
for a guy.
I mean he had seven world metals,
metals,
done.
Everything he did,
if he didn't win May,
maybe that metal was sold.
You know?
I mean,
he was so good,
but brought this up the other day when
he was wrestling,
he was wrestling for minute matches,
so can you keep a pace up?
Can you hit [inaudible] take downs?
Can you do three towns around or four
takedowns around over a period of 15
minutes.
Most guys can't do that.
Well,
it's also the frame that he's used to
carrying around for wrestling is
probably the wrong frame for Emma who
should probably tone it down a little
bit.
You know,
I mean,
he's a big fog and you look at him when
he steps on the.
Not the weigh ins because he's a little
dehydrated,
but when he steps into the octagon,
that fucking guy looks like a cartoon.
I mean his waist is 27 inches.
His fucking shoulders a retarded.
Everything is just as bubble muscle
bubble.
Last bubble thighs just.
He looks like just a super freak.
Super Freak athlete.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
His.
Well,
he saw his wrestling videos when he was
active.
Obscene him.
Yeah.
He's amazing.
Unbelievable speed.
His ability to close the distance is
shocking in mma.
You know,
we saw that in the tovaras fight,
he tovaras move forward and he stepped
in while the virus is moving forward and
blasting him in the face with an elbow,
but it was just like two guys moving at
completely different speeds.
He's the only guy I've seen to an ankle
pick in an MMA fight tour and James
Tony,
that was a little saying,
oh,
that was where I was a little single way
from did it was a fight in Germany.
He literally was in a fighting stance,
reached down from an outside grip,
grabbed the guy's ankle,
lift it up over his head,
and the guy hit the mic.
I want to see it.
That guy is different.
He's.
But again,
you have to look at are we fighting for
25 minutes where we're fighting for in a
foreman in a wrestling match,
because there had been some great
wrestlers,
amazing wrestlers who have come into
Emma and completely failed because for
some reason they can't tune it in for 15
minutes.
You know,
who I really wish would have stuck in
there,
but it just wasn't his thing as rule on
gardener.
Yeah,
I got my management start.
It really unlocked a lot of ways.
My training start with Rulon rulon when
he fought Yoshida.
That was his first MMA fight,
right?
It was.
He had never been in a fight before.
We're in Japan and they were.
Dan fought somebody on October 31st,
so they flew him in to Japan to Tokyo in
October 31st and he was fighting exactly
eight weeks later.
December 31st.
Was that New Year's eve?
Sorry.
So he didn't show up in California for
16 days,
so that eight weeks to live when we're
gone.
Two and a half weeks.
I've gotten six weeks left,
six weeks left.
We have travel on Christmas,
so now let's go down to five weeks and I
think he went out of town 12 days.
What he would have.
There's no days left.
He would have a speaking engagement
here.
I gotta go,
I'll be back tomorrow.
We'd miss a day here.
He missed a day there,
so there's no days.
That's no day.
It was a suit.
It was a real challenge for sure,
but it's like five days of training or
something crazy.
It's more than that,
I forget what it all came out to be,
but it made me kind of refocus myself to
go,
okay,
we have a limited amount of time.
He's never been in a fight before,
like not on the school ground.
Nothing like that.
Too Big.
It really are.
You gonna stay an eighth grader,
you find Ruan I don't think since
fucking heads as big as this table.
Yeah,
so it kind of had to decide,
okay,
here's what we're going to do and then
deal with all the mental side of things.
Anxiety,
have a fight coming up and that's a big
deal.
A lot to work in all that time.
So it was a unique challenge for him,
but I like his striking approach to just
jabbed the fuck out of them to stepped
in and hit him with that goddamn
telephone pole of a hand of it.
It's just junk.
It's like extending a big telephone
poles and funk.
We worked on like four things.
The same thing when so could you fought
Nogueira the fight that you saw?
That's what we did over and over for six
weeks.
So when you.
When you put an athlete in these
situations where they're in over their
head,
you have to get super focused.
That funnel has gotta get totally
narrative,
okay,
here's what we're doing.
This is the only thing you're allowed to
think about.
Now you take care of everything else in
their life so they don't even have to
focus on it,
so then when they come in there,
you give them their best chance of
winning by doing this one thing.
It's a different strategy.
And so for Gardner,
what were the things you worked on that
job?
Closing the distance.
Don't worry about throwing right hands.
It's hard to throw a punch off the
backhand if you don't have experience.
Feels very exposed.
Chink comes up.
Where's my distance?
So behind that job?
Yeah,
he had probably a hundred pounds on your
cheetah in the clinch position.
I was fairly confident about that.
And then to get on top,
cover his hips,
grab as risk posture up and punch him.
No,
he didn't do a great job with the ground
and pound,
but we keep it very simple.
He was allowed to wear wrestling shoes
too.
Yeah.
Which was,
yeah,
you get a big guy like that with
wrestling shoes on and grips totally
did.
Yeah,
good luck taking him down.
Good fucking luck.
Olympic gold medalists.
The last guy,
I mean he did.
Who?
Who the fuck did he beat in the finals
was a weird thing.
Was the grip thing,
right?
Yeah.
It's basically I give it is tied.
One guy gets to lock first.
If you lock first and you break your
grip,
then it's over.
You could appoint.
So rule [inaudible] curl on locked.
He broke his grip and that was it.
That's kind of ridiculous.
Yeah.
They call that a point.
That was a fairly recent rule to.
It wasn't like pitching [inaudible].
That was 14 years in the time in that
timeframe.
They just recently changed the rules to
keep up with wrestling,
so I don't.
The rules always changed a little bit,
but that's not a victory.
I mean it is,
but it isn't.
You know what I mean?
It's like God damn.
Especially when you're dealing with a
guy who's probably the greatest Russian
heavyweight of all time,
he's probably one of the greatest
athlete.
Olympic athletes have time.
He won every world and Olympic
championships for like 13 years.
He never lost the match.
And international never lost a match in
international competition until he met
Roland in the finals and lost because of
his grip broke.
I mean,
nothing happened.
You didn't get taken down and get throw
into his head.
Nothing.
Those,
there's images of him.
There's images of Carrillo.
Jamie pull up one of the images of
Karalyn
Andrew Carrillo and there's an image of
him where he's fucking picking someone
up and reverse lynching his teeth and
he's got this fucking psychotic look in
his eyes and his whole body doesn't even
look real.
I mean in the middle of straining.
It's like he's got some extra muscles
that like,
you know,
when you see the hulk,
like in the vendors isn't even real
muscles.
Like he's got muscles that don't belong
in the human body.
They're like extra connections and weird
little,
you know,
like the hulk is,
is not just extra muscular.
He's not,
it's not a human frame.
That's a totally different frame.
There was something about corral and
when he's fucking a supplement program,
like,
um,
I think it probably had to do with a lot
of stuff that,
uh,
it's very hard to get a store.
You'd probably have to go to a scientist
and you probably don't swallow it.
It probably goes in through a needle
into the muscle and just directly into
the muscle.
Well,
you know,
his family,
his parents were small.
His parents were like five,
five and five,
seven.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
there's a crazy photo from sports
illustrated of Corella and walking with
his parents.
There's the picture.
Look at that,
look at that fucking big fucking
fisherman.
He think he wanted to win in the 80s.
Dan,
Dan Henderson,
he sim,
she's now that could evolve.
It used to go over to Russia and they
would train with those guys.
So they got so good that they will go
spend.
They've go spend months at a time there
and heath would tell me Kremlin would
sit on the ground under a rope legs and
just arms come up with 300 pounds,
climbing up a rope with no arms up and
down,
up and down.
I'm not surprised he was a freak athlete
is freakishly strong.
So much so that guys would flatten out
on their stomachs to try to keep him
from picking them up and throwing them
on their heads at heavyweight crazy.
Yeah.
You just take 300 pound guys from a
fully flattened out position and he
would just scoop them up like they were
nothing and just launch them through the
fucking air.
Only father time beat that guy just
after awhile.
You know,
he's running hot for father time and
Rulon Gardner Gardner.
Yeah.
Sort of,
sort of beat them.
I mean tactically beat him.
It didn't beat him like he beat
everybody else,
but gardener.
I was like,
man,
when I saw him beat Yoshida was like,
if this fucking guy really dedicates
himself and really dial down and gets to
an optimum weight and you know,
I mean,
who the fuck is going to?
He was supposed to fight again I suppose
by fader.
They offered him over $1 million to
fight.
I did those deals.
They didn't offer $1 million.
Now the fight was for Nogueira on two
weeks notice,
but that was a different offer.
But there was an offer for fader.
No,
there wasn't.
So it's bullshit.
It was,
it was the first deal I ever did as a
manager was 10 years ago and they called
up.
They wanted to fight no guarantee on two
weeks notice or tend to accept that,
but pride was always like that.
You always found out two or weeks here
you're going to fight
rule on Herman train.
He's like,
man,
I haven't been training.
You didn't train for the first one.
Go out there,
shoot a double leg.
If you want,
stick your arm at the Yo.
Nothing's going to happen.
You're going to be fine.
And we told him to take it,
but I'm just saying if you get scared,
you know,
whatever,
which really put that in his head.
If you get scared putting,
leave your arm.
No,
of course not.
I'm not going to say four sided already,
but I mean really what's going to
happen?
You're just going to get your big goal
out there and if you get and you don't
like or you feel tapped out the care
setting so he's not going to try to
break your arm.
So it was a crazy like six hour
negotiated back and forth and we're at a
huge number and it turned out to be a
three fight deal worth well over a
million dollars.
The majority of it was for that fight on
two weeks notice.
And then he decided that he didn't want
to do it the next day,
but it didn't end there.
And then he was given the opportunity on
two days notice to fight butter being at
the,
uh,
at the pride event in Vegas.
Two days.
Notice how the Athletic Commission
sanction that.
Well,
they had,
it all worked out.
He had to fly down that day.
Physicals and everything were all lined
up.
They would have found a way to get it
done.
He would've smashed butter bean.
Come on up.
Been one AA battery.
Won't be like a turtle on its back.
Yeah.
He was smiling.
Well,
you do have to worry about butter.
Been tagging you and you're coming in.
But who's got a fuck an iron chin too.
He's a big guy.
Cracked though.
That was the baddest really fat guy ever
because he English four honors morbidly
obese.
He wasn't like fat.
Like Roy Nelson Fat.
You know?
He makes Roy Nelson look like Michael
Phelps.
You know when you have the two of them
standing next to each other,
butter bean has like that weird underarm
fat,
that fat that makes your arms stick out
like this.
We shared a locker room with him.
He takes his own hands to those.
He.
Yeah,
he's a motherfucker,
a barbecue cook.
See Him cooking barbecue.
He's a super nice guy.
Really good guy.
Yeah.
Got The shit out of some barbecue.
That's why he's with that big.
I've got one autograph for my adult life
and it was some butter bay and I gave it
to my dad.
I'm like,
listen man,
you get assigned working.
Oh,
that's cool.
But yeah,
so rule on just decided no,
no more and it just wasn't for him.
Now you know,
he just went bankrupt.
There was this big thing,
some online.
They're auctioning off all of his stuff.
His stuff from the Olympics.
Sad.
Yeah.
And then he was on biggest loser.
He was like more than 350 pounds,
450 pounds and he lost 150 pounds or
something.
Like what?
Is that just bad food or is he just.
I mean,
to get that big,
you need genetics to get that big.
I would have a hard time getting to 450
pounds is a big guy.
He's got a huge barrel chest and he
likes to eat.
There is the biggest loser.
Jesus Christ.
That was sad.
Seeing him too on this kind of freak
show
on TV.
You know,
this is a goddamn Olympic gold medalist.
So this is a great wrestler,
great athlete.
And you've seen them on the biggest
loser.
It's like,
this is really the only way he can lose
weight.
I mean,
I don't understand it.
That's how it goes,
right?
I mean,
the life of the athlete.
Now when you're.
You're a trainer,
but you're also a manager.
I mean you're involved in a lot of
different.
A long development process.
For me,
I started,
I got a chiropractic degree and we go
back.
I wrestled at Arizona State and met Dan
Henderson there.
Heat sims were there.
Randy couture would be out there a
little bit and then I moved to
California after that year later started
chiropractic school and continued.
Dan and I were roommates for probably
six years,
so the whole time I was in chiropractic
school,
we would have training camps that are,
have sarandrea come spend a month before
the 96 Olympics.
So there were always guys coming in.
So the only people that I ever worked
with were world class athletes.
And as,
as the transition,
Emma came in,
Dan was the number one wrestler in the
country and he made 12 grand a year.
What?
As you get paid.
So if you're the number on the national
team,
he got a paycheck and that paycheck,
thousand bucks a month.
Yeah.
So he got a call in,
I think it's 2008 to fight in Brazil.
Well,
how much does it pay as well?
It's three fights in one night.
If you win,
you get $12,000.
And Dan I think had been in street
fights in his whole life and he goes,
okay,
I went down,
there is only Dan Henderson [inaudible]
those three fights and that's his
career.
Got started.
Now we've got one.
One of them by submission.
Yeah.
It was the coolest submission ever.
Guy.
He was a guillotine.
He was standing up and the guy passed
out on his feet and Dan ended up in a
mount position.
Yeah.
And then he beat another Carlson gracie
black belt and the guy tapped.
The crowd didn't like it.
The crowds storm the cage.
It was a crazy moment.
The crowds didn't like that.
The guy tapped,
the crowd thought the stoppage was
early.
Uh,
and then there was a little bit of a
riot,
but the cage was really tall and they,
they kind of charged the Cajun Navy.
The lights went out or something that
wasn't there.
Just in second hand on this one.
It's been awhile.
The lights used to go out in those
Brazilian mma valley.
[inaudible] shit was going back to the
cage.
Yeah.
Eugenio today.
And uh,
um,
uh,
Henzel Gracie,
remember the lights went out and hands
on was losing.
So he,
yes,
down in there.
And then the guy then said,
no,
I've lost my momentum.
I don't want to fight again.
So he didn't want to continue,
lost my.
And I think that he said something like
that.
Okay.
So Dan.
So Dan went and won the tournament.
That's how he kind of at least got his
entry into mma and then ended up in,
in rings that this King of King
Tournament,
that was 32 men.
It was open wait tournament [inaudible]
guys know on that as well going to say
he was in the next year
or the year before something fader
fought and rings.
But I don't know if he was in the
tournament,
I'd have to go look at a record,
but Dan fights.
He fights,
um,
to win it.
He fought three times a one 80 foot
ballou.
He fought a Gilbert ival and he fought.
Um,
no gear.
Big Nogueira wow.
It was funny on the bus.
Know Gary told me this,
years later,
nugget one the term,
the next year they paid Dan $200,000
in cash as Japanese gangsters.
We'll send a trash walked in afterwards
and they handed him $200,000.
Guys do what?
The cash.
We didn't really know what to do with
it.
It was me,
Dan and randy walking around the streets
of Tokyo.
$200,000
in a backpack trying to figure out,
do we wire this wire it.
How'd you get it back to America?
It just ended up brought it back and Dan
claimed it and pay the attorneys do
that.
You could tell a hundred grand.
You just have to tell them because he
wasn't just selling coke and Tokyo.
Yeah.
As long as you go,
I have this money.
Oh,
I see.
You know,
everyone knows about it was John John
when he fought over in Japan against
frank trigg.
Yeah.
The first fight I ever cornered someone
in.
Oh,
was it really?
Yeah.
I acquired frank trigg in that fight.
Wow.
In 1998.
Randy in in a way on that.
They took the money and they'll do it to
like all the brothers.
They all brought it over.
I'm sorry.
You only have to figure out how to do
it.
Chef pants you don't have.
You can't have more than 10,000
bucks on you without claiming it.
You allow to be a baller with like 9,999
bucks.
I think in those days.
Everyone who fought in pride probably
shove some in their underwear when they
were coming through and cross your
fingers.
Right.
Everything was paid in cash over there
because you know when you fill out a
customs form,
it asks you,
do you have more than $10,000?
He collects no and weird month number.
You know,
I have to pick a number,
right?
Yeah.
They have to pick a number.
I think that's like one of those numbers
to like if you deposit it in their bank,
like red flags go off,
it's more than 10 grand so you have to
like sneak in like nine that started,
that started in the 80s and for all the
coke in Miami.
Ah,
but if it wasn't for coke in Miami in a
mattress to be.
No.
Miami.
Yeah.
More more banks per capita than anywhere
else in the fucking country for a
reason.
And the cowboys.
My favorite documentary and cooking
cowboys too.
Have you seen to maybe even better?
Yeah.
Billy Corbin,
I gotta get that guy on the podcast one
of these days.
The Guy who produced the awesome guy,
fucking great documentaries,
man.
It's so well done.
It just such a crazy,
crazy fucking story.
So anyway,
Dan,
one,
$200,000
in cash.
But it was funny you saw he really saw
it.
Dan was made of in that because I think
he probably took his first fight was
with Gilbert evil and he probably took
them down 14 times and then knocked him
down at the beginning,
which had never been done before.
He almost are barred.
Then he probably,
someone will have to come.
I think it was well over 10 takedowns
and when he came to the back,
because you have a fairly quick
turnaround time and those tournament
days,
it's a whole different mentality.
So you go back into the locker room
yourself out?
Yeah,
in his head,
never.
His forearms were so
swollen.
He couldn't really make a make a fist
and then he fought Bob Lou.
I just think so much grappling,
so much squeezing and they just weren't
settling down.
Then they went and fought Bob Ballou and
his knee got hurt and I remember turned
into randy between before the
[inaudible].
I don't know if he can.
I don't know if he can go out there and
Dan was hobbling around.
He preaches laying there.
He couldn't move at all,
couldn't move his leg.
His arms are still swollen mean he was.
His whole body was seizing up and we've
Kinda got them moving a little bit and
that's when they play the national
anthem.
Before the finals,
you could see his whole physiology and
posture change was really a cool moment
to see and everything changed and he
went down there and and fought a very
close fight with Nogueira giving up and
all those guys weighed over 240 pound
Dan is every bit of 200 pounds.
He fought all three of them and won a
bunch of money and that's kind of how he
got his start end up in pride after that
national anthem fire to my papa.
You can see,
you can see,
he can see it.
Shane is a whole change in him when it
happened.
Wow.
It has to be something above and beyond
yourself to get through moments like
that.
If it's nationalism,
whatever it is,
they'll carry you through.
He got it done and they ended up ended
up in pride after that.
Wow.
Well,
he fought in the UFC to write early days
early to Helen go as.
And I was there for that 97.
And um,
what's his name?
Carla.
Kinda dreadlock hair.
Canadian good grappler.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Carlos.
Carlos Newton.
Yeah.
Carlos knew it was a very good rapport.
He was one of the first,
like really complex grapplers that would
fight,
you know,
no Ge style complex grappling.
He was fantastic.
He was really good.
He is a vicious,
vicious fucking grappling.
I'm going to fight with him and mad.
He got mad.
He was in a triangle amount who slammed
him on his head and didn't even know he
won.
No one knew what was happening or both.
Our both out.
Yeah.
He choked me out.
He was out and as Matt Hughes was
getting choked out,
he slammed him on his head and knocked
him out cold.
So Matt Hughes woke up the champion and
that was after Carlos had caught and pat
miletich and the first ever bulldog
choke in MMA economy.
The school you're at that school yard,
headlock and sat back,
which is fucking very effective.
Move hard.
It's hard to get out of.
Hard to get out of.
That's a weird move that people sort of
disrespect.
It's weird because they respect the
[inaudible] [inaudible] I guess the good
team,
even as even they respect the standing
18 like John Jones did on Machita are
and Weidman did on who did hooded me,
catching the standard routine.
I forget it was a.
It doesn't matter,
but they don't.
For whatever reason,
the school yard choke is like,
oh,
come on.
It's because there's so much discretion.
Choke.
It's brutal.
It's probably the strongest of all jokes
if you can get there.
Yeah.
Get your backing into it and you're
pushing off with your legs and digging
in with it.
I mean a bunch of guys that got it.
Chris lytle got it on Tki.
You know,
it's happened a few times in the since
then,
but I think I'm pretty sure when Newton
got pat miletich and it was the first
time anybody ever pull that choke off
and that's a,
that's another one of those techniques.
It's like,
oh,
those things that's real,
that's a real move.
Okay.
You know,
and over the course of the x amount of
years,
so 21 years since the UFC started,
we've,
every now and then we'll see one of
those things pop up and then you see
them everywhere.
You know,
you see one pop up like,
oh,
now it's everywhere.
Yeah,
it's cool though,
isn't it?
It's the,
it's the,
it's a real joy in this sport.
It's a development.
Yeah.
They'll kind of seeing that through.
I love when new things like that come
up,
you know.
And one of the new things that you're
seeing now is,
um,
I haven't seen it in the UFC yet,
but I know we're going to see it soon.
Is that baseball bat choke from the
bottom?
Have you seen that?
There's this crazy new choke.
The guys who are doing it was a good
joke and someone figured out how to do
it.
No biggie.
And it's like when you're on the bottom,
when the guy's on top of you inside
control,
you wrap your arm over his head like
this with like palm up.
You grab it like this and pinch it down
and it's death.
It's death when guys are good at it.
They clamp a hold of your neck and
you're going out.
You've got a couple seconds to either
tabs,
both sides,
right?
Both sides,
and if guys are good at it,
you know it's one of those things where
you teach a guy how to do a good routine
and he doesn't really know it yet.
Be showing the movement and you say,
okay,
get me into gear to and as soon as he
tries to slap it on,
you grab his wrist,
you pull your head up,
your posture,
you get yourself out of it and you're
free.
You know it's because you're better at
the defense than he is,
but when it's a position that you're not
used to defending and this baseball bat
job position than a lot of people are
not used to fund these.
A bunch of positions that people just
not used to finding themselves in those
critical seconds.
That's critical,
may not even seconds like fractions of a
second.
From when you realize that choke is
getting on to where you have to defend
yourself.
And if you don't do it at six on either
your neck,
like fuck,
like you might not be able to get out of
this.
There's that.
The window between safe and fucking.
I missed the boat I missed upon.
I'm fucking drowning shit.
Your destinies in that window.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
The destinies in those windows and the
scrambles also,
and this is a thing that we're seeing in
mma a lot lately is scrambles off the
cage and the striking in the scrambles
you're seeing like these,
these little mini moments,
you know,
where the guys are separating and one
guy will land in need of the body hard,
neither the body and the other is an
opening for both guys.
But one guy maybe decided to take a
little bit of a break,
breathe,
you know,
and pace himself.
And the other guy pushed it and
capitalized in land.
That's where I spend 95% of my.
If I'm coaching two sides,
it's really just kind of artist
development,
right?
So there's the management side to it,
negotiating,
deal,
sponsor,
that type of thing.
There's a healthcare side of it because
you have to take care of your body.
They're just helping people deal with
the media.
There's finding developmental fights and
then there's training aspect,
so what I do on the training side of
things is just what you said.
It's it's those moments,
those transitional moments,
so we'll have experts come in who will
do the Jujitsu,
had finished that show,
what's the best way,
and the strikers who will hold pads and
the coach for that.
My job is to kind of tie everything all
together and tying it together.
You have to have a good understanding of
the big picture and understand how you
start connecting these dots between all
these different things and that's the
key to where [inaudible] heading in.
It's not who can do the best arm bar
anymore.
It's this transitional moments.
That's the why are you doing what you're
doing and finding those opportunities
and those moments.
Yeah.
It's also we've had a chance to see this
progress and we see the whole game
change or used to be like for a long
time or the Mark Coleman era.
It was the big powerful wrestler.
They could take guys down and smash
them.
And then those guys were fucked body
body head.
Yeah.
But then we found guys like Maury Smith
that could survive.
They had really good cardio and then he
would start dragging you into the later
rounds and kicking the shit out of your
legs.
So then it was like,
oh fuck,
there's that,
you know.
And then in pride you saw cro,
cop,
Cro,
cop came along and change it.
Now here's a guy who is got vicious
takedown defense.
His take down defense is catlike and if
he kicks you,
you're not even going to know what the
fuck happened.
You're just going to be out cold.
And his highlight reel over and over
again is him head kicking the Shit Outta
Emelianenko head,
kicking the shit out of a grove of
chanting head kicking the shit out of
everybody.
Boom,
boom.
Vandelay Boehm.
Everybody's going asleep.
Left high kick poem.
It's like fuck,
now this,
this guy,
you know.
And then,
um,
then we realized when he came over to
the UFC,
you got to see a couple of things going
on.
One,
there's a lot of speculation like what
was he doing with his body when he was
in pride?
What was he doing as far as like
supplementation?
What was he doing as far as like the
performance enhancing drugs?
Was he involved in anything because he
was a different fighter.
He's a different fighter from pride to
the UFC and then he fought Gonzaga and
you saw the difference between what
happens when you get stuck on the cage.
What happens when a guy is not used to
training or fighting in a cage?
I'm,
I don't even think he had a cage in his
gym.
You know,
before the Gonzaga fine.
I don't think it was used to that shit
at all.
And elbows on the ground.
That's another big element that the UFC
had over pride and Gonzaga fucked him up
before he ever had kicked him.
He was just beating the shit out of him
on the ground and elbowed him in the
head.
We've got to see that.
This,
this transition.
You know when a guy like Gonzaga head
kick,
a guy like cro cop,
that's an epic moment in that moment,
and he crumbled was a cro cop,
cro cop was an epic moment in mma.
He got to see that there's,
first of all,
there's another level.
The level that you were fighting in and
pride,
as amazing as it was is not the highest
level.
Guys like Fujita guys like Gilbert Ivo,
very tough guys where they're not the
high level.
They're not.
They're not the junior dos Santos is of
the world.
They're not the Cain Velasquez of the
words.
There's a whole nother level.
There's a whole nother thing that's a
beautiful thing about having several
organizations,
but that's a confusing thing about
having several,
several organizations because the guy
looks like a world beater when he's
fighting guys who are like mid level
fighters,
but then he goes over to the UFC and you
know,
you put them in there against someone
like like a lumbar or like a high level
guy and you get to see what he's really
made out of.
There's probably not that talent pool to
support multiple organizations.
Not yet,
right,
but it seems like they could develop it.
The problem is there's very few people
really develop and talent,
so you have have kinda like a couple of
different pressure.
The thing.
So here's my.
If I'm giving advice to anyone who wants
to fight and you think you're going to
be good,
you have to get out of a team,
individual group training situation as
quickly as possible.
In what way?
Okay.
So when,
when I got most started,
he hadn't fought before.
He went from no fights to beat into
Sassy and becoming strikeforce champion
in 19 months.
And every single workout he did through
that entire time was for him on that
day.
So I see that's what you're saying.
So yeah.
The auntie she gave the air for group
training is for sparring sessions.
But if,
if you come from a karate background,
I come from a Jujitsu background.
Our developmental approach to fighting
in the UFC was going to be very
different if we do it the same,
the neither one of us are going to
progress as quickly as possible.
So you have to find someone who's
willing to work,
really invest time and energy into and
create a training structure and program
for you that you can get from here to
here as quickly as possible.
I'm a firm believer that starting at the
bottom is the worst place to start.
You have to take what skill someone
already does.
Well,
I'm presuming they came from a
background.
Maybe you wrestled or maybe you had a
black belt in Jujitsu.
You have.
You have to take those approaches and as
quickly as possible get them to here and
they're often very different
trajectories.
What do you do with a young kid who's
coming up that doesn't have any skills?
They're just wanting to learn
[inaudible].
I don't really work with those guys.
So what would you say to one though?
Like say if someone came along like some
15 year old kid says,
Hey,
I'm a huge UFC fan.
I want to fight him and Mary A,
how should I get started?
I would have him pick one discipline to
start.
If you're 15 years old,
go wrestle.
If you,
if you are more drawn to boxing or
kickboxing and then go do that along the
way,
play and experiment a little bit,
but athlete development is changing now.
There's this,
this trend for when kids are as young as
five,
six years old,
that there's these intensive training
program.
She have larger cities where there's
good resource,
good coaching and good facilities.
They take these kids from an early age,
maybe they train with football or
basketball or hockey,
something like this with the intent of
developing professional athletes.
This approaches almost producing zero
professional athletes.
The ones who are successful are the ones
who played three and four sports growing
up
and then they get to a certain age and
then they start narrowing in and kind of
defining the best way to be.
What are they going to do?
The Australians did it before the
Olympics in [inaudible].
They started to take it a whole bunch of
metrics on their athletes finding,
okay,
you're not good enough to win a medal
here.
Have you thought about this?
Try this.
And as a result,
the Ozzies,
they've won national governing body for,
um,
for their Olympic sports development.
As a result,
they did 10 times per capita.
The amount of metals at the US did in
2012.
Um,
in,
in the UK,
they did the same thing.
They took it a little bit further as an
example of one woman who was good,
I think she was some type of distance
runner or something that all sorts of
measurements,
like the,
the risk to elbow measurement.
And this is more technical than than I
know,
but they found she had this certain
measurement in here and said,
okay,
you're not gonna win a medal on this.
Have you ever considered rowing?
She goes,
I've never done.
Wrote three years later she was Olympic
champion.
What's,
you could be at a little bit rowing
champion three years thinking about if
you are already a well trained athlete
for something else.
It involved that type of cardiovascular
stuff.
Then you have this specific biomechanics
that fits.
So if you know what those biomechanics
or you know what to look for in an
athlete,
you can steer them in this direction.
The UK did great with metal counts.
That's amazing.
So I take the same approach.
I've always done this.
I was never.
I wrestled in college,
but I was never.
There was never like Dan,
you know,
I was never a great in one thing,
but I was always really good and I think
it'll lava came from my chiropractic
background and really looking at
somebody figuring out,
okay,
here's what's going on with you.
Finally we communicate with them and
saying,
okay,
I think this is the best course of
action for you based on all these
things.
Well,
I live now.
I had trained a little bit with it.
I love the rubber card,
right?
But for someone like Dan who's got a
long torso,
zero flexibility and a great wrestling
with a sledge hammer right hand,
should we invest time and energy on
learning a rubber guard?
Probably not the best strategy for them.
Right?
There's other approaches because to get
good at it,
you have to put all this energy.
Pat was another great example for him.
He was heavy punching,
great wrestling,
so we're not going to spend a whole lot
of time at age two pets,
maybe 30 years old.
We can't spend a whole lot of time
working at tax from your back.
He has shorter legs and he's a bitch.
I've never seen him and be able to hold
him down.
So where do you invest his time and
energy?
It comes back to the whole thing and I'm
amazed that we don't have enough time.
All this.
We don't have enough time.
You have to now pick and choose,
so the more information you have to kind
of make those decisions and help funnel
someone,
you can speed up an athlete's
development considerably.
If you're stuck in a training room,
I go to a big mega,
mega camp with 70 fighters or something.
You're not going to get the quality of
attention from coaches.
If you're coming up and you learn the
techniques that everyone else is doing,
you're not learning the techniques that
are best for you.
In theory,
there's a lot of guys that are saying
that,
you know,
they're,
they're switching camps because they're
saying that the camp that they're at,
they don't get enough attention and when
they spar it's just wars.
No one,
no one's being real tactical.
Do you see that a lot?
All the time.
You can,
uh,
really I can watch it one time in one
training session,
three or four people.
I've always had a really small group of
people who have had success moving
people up quickly and helping them
become really good at what they do by
taking this approach.
And if I had,
if I was managing 40 people where I was
at an event once I heard this one guy,
a pretty well known fighter go,
I tell my managers all time,
just think about me for one minute a
day.
And I turned to him and said,
well,
I better very careful what you ask for.
She just may get that,
you know,
my theory is this,
if you're going to ask somebody to go
get in their underwear and fight in a
cage for their money to pay their rent
that month,
that person deserves a lot of attention,
especially if if,
if my income comes with their success
and I'm saying,
Oh hey,
I'm going to sit here and you're gonna,
go in the cage and fight.
You deserve every.
Everything that I can give you.
That's what you deserve,
but it's hard for people to find someone
like you that's willing to do that.
There's not that many of you guys out
there.
There's a lot of guys that are doing it
with all due respect.
I think they're doing a cursory job.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
Like if you want becoming a manager and
Emma May now go up to any fighter and
say,
I can get you a bunch of sponsorships
and they'll immediately sign with you.
Right.
There's no big picture thought to what's
being done in 95% of these guys.
It's a lot like being a young standup
comedians that you're starving and
you're looking for someone to come
along.
It's going to alleviate some of that
financial pressure,
so we're going to get you gigs.
I get you sponsors,
I get your fights.
I can get you into bellator or UFC.
I can get you into the TFA.
Whatever the fuck you gonna fight in.
Yeah.
That's a big thing is like these young
fighters that are just fucking barely
hanging on.
They're barely making ends meet and
someone comes along and they're smooth
talk and then they got to get rid of
those fuckers when things go good.
The chance to have that guy or or
whoever developing you to have longterm
success in your careers.
It's virtually slim to none.
Evan will be in the old ticket
commission check a commission check
here.
Maybe it's a bad business decision for
me is probably ways to make more money
by by having 40 people,
but there was not to be excellent and
we're.
We're here to win championships.
If you ever see me in the corner,
if you ever see me working with someone
because I expect them to go win that
fight in my heart,
I believe that they're going to go win
that fight or us.
I shouldn't be there.
You advise coming to take the fight with
cormier that had to be a fight where
you're like,
Ooh,
this is a tricky one.
It was like seven days notice.
Yeah,
are all tricky.
I got most are like that and dreaming
Sengoku as well.
I create a bidding war between dream and
Sango.
Como didn't have anything to his name
and he fought for a huge person.
I mean he was good for awhile after that
one fight and it went really well for
him.
He went and knocked out travis view in a
minute or two and it started his whole
career with pat.
Pat was is probably the most challenging
experience you've had with somebody
because from the time
I started working with him,
people knew he was good.
Like I saw him spar gifts to us in three
weeks before Jon Jones and pat was six
weeks off of minor knee injury and I saw
how that one,
if you've ever found anyone who's
trained with pet companies went,
oh boy nightmares.
Just fucking savage.
He is so good.
So he saw the kingsbury fight,
Kingsbury fight.
You got to see what is really keeping.
You know what?
That was 50% of him.
That's amazing.
I still wasn't terribly pleased with
that performance.
He was.
He's so much better than that.
He's a tough fuck.
He says in Kingsbury was in there.
Not too when he was in there to get by,
which is hard to finish someone in those
situations,
but when he was there to win for the
first couple of minutes,
but in June,
like I read some interviews,
he said,
you know,
my,
my personal goal here is to get through
this.
It wasn't,
I'm going to smash this guy.
Was it different mentality?
He had done a few IOWASCA sessions and
that sort of changed his whole outlook
on life,
kind of become a very different person.
Something happens to crossover to the
other side.
Yeah.
Especially if you're a guy who's made a
living being a savage,
you know,
and then all of a sudden it's difficult
to continue for long periods of time.
Yeah.
So pat got the call and I got the whole
story was true.
I had 50 guys turned him down.
It got to the point where I'm offering
promoters like,
how much do I have to pay you to get him
a fight?
And the best stories is one promoter on
the east coast said,
okay,
I'm want sign him to a fight deal.
I said,
okay,
because you have to get me a hundred
tickets.
So how much are the tickets?
$30.
I said,
okay,
she want me to pay you $3,000
every time.
Pat Fights.
Okay,
I'll pay that and you have to pay for
your travel and hotel.
So now we're just laughing.
So now that will cause it to do this.
He wanted exclusive deal.
I have to pay him $15,000
to sign pat to an exclusive deal.
It's ridiculous.
Even that guy couldn't find them in
upon.
Wow.
So you agree to this and saw I'm not
going to do that,
but I still will find us an opponent.
Of course you'd never had anybody and
that's a hilarious deal though.
That W,
W,
pat and I were laughing.
Can you say what organization or member
three letters on the east coast.
I have no idea what the letters mean,
but we were going everywhere.
I mean if,
if you were.
I was,
I was trying,
I would try to find opponents for him
and then set him up for,
okay,
I have an opponent,
here's,
this will pay for all this.
No one wanted to fight pet coming.
So we got the call.
It was,
it was a whole mad rush at this point,
three weeks early,
he had started working at this coffee
shop.
So he's getting up at two in the
morning,
going to the coffee shop,
training,
sleeping five hours a night.
This went on for three weeks and I
barged into the coffee shop and said,
hey,
dan is on the phone.
You wanna fight Daniel.
And he goes,
yes,
absolutely.
And that's how everything got going,
but we've got to quit.
The job,
because they didn't want to talk on that
until they told me he was fire.
They said,
pack your stuff and go home.
I'm like,
ah,
see,
and then literally 12 hours later,
10 hours later,
he's live on Fox talking shit to Daniel.
I hadn't.
Hadn't slept in 24 hours and then.
But here's what people don't.
People don't understand all the see all
the behind the scenes stuff.
So that was the day.
So 24 hours,
no sleep,
and then we have to do all of your
medicals in a day.
That's a huge task and there's a whole
bunch of media.
Try to work some training in there and
then couple days later we're on.
I think I have.
There's four nights,
I think I slept two hours a night so
that by the time we get to vegas he's
super happy,
relaxed but tired.
And I have this,
this picture of this gauge.
You mentioned a pressure gauge in the
middle of the needles right here.
This is like we are now,
we're calm.
Everything is centered.
The needle goes this way.
It's all called call negative emotions,
like maybe a little worry,
anxiety,
fear,
panic,
you know,
we started to bury into the red section.
On the other side is all positive
emotions will cost the green side and we
have like happiness,
joy,
excitement,
caution,
confidence,
and then you kind of get to this manic
like almost right before your fight.
You're so ready to go.
If your needle is on either side of
this,
you're burning energy,
so even if you get into a sitter,
impat was super happy.
He was great.
The media,
I felt great about things all week
because he was so relaxed,
feeling good,
but he was almost feeling too excited
and too happy.
So wherever that needle is on either
side,
you're burning energy.
Then come fight time.
You haven't slept for three weeks.
You've been doing this job.
All of a sudden you have this huge
adrenaline dress.
I'm,
no one will fight me.
I'm in the UFC and a co main event.
Here we are against Daniel.
I think what happened in the fight is
he,
he stopped being a participant in,
became an observer.
He stepped out of the moment in that
situation,
so it was just overwhelmed by it or the
whole thing.
Yeah,
but not overwhelmed.
Like in the sense that it was too much.
You didn't want to be there.
There's different types of overwhelmed,
right?
He had just expanded so much energy that
you want.
You only have so much energy.
You can only push so hard even if it's
all really good,
positive things.
If you have all these amazing things
happening in your life,
you still have to take a breath,
return to center.
It's like if you take a pendulum,
you hold it up,
it's going to swing wildly for awhile
before it settles back down again.
Your job,
if you're going to do,
uh,
be involved with the sport like this is
you have to keep super centered and
focused.
So,
oh,
I won a bunch of money.
Okay.
Oh,
I just lost the fight.
Okay.
And the guy who is best at this,
I think just naturally personality wise
was Dan.
Dan was always right here.
We're in a big fight.
Lose something.
I mean,
feel Dan could win $1 million.
It okay,
just a little bump up and really be.
He was always very centered Lavonne and
I think that's one reason why he was so
successful that pat is also like that,
but he was just thrown into this
environment where there was so much
energy being spent.
By the time he came into the fight,
it was difficult to to involved with
that.
Now
I'm not saying that he would have one.
Daniel was clearly the better fighter.
Don't misunderstand what I'm saying
here,
but you have to kind of look at the
whole arc of,
of this experience and not only just
with fight week,
you have to take that same overall view
of your career.
So if you're a young fighter and you're
struggling,
that's good.
You know,
struggle,
worried about how you're gonna,
pay your rent.
That's not a bad thing.
You have to look at everything that
you're doing and the bigger picture of
things.
And for me,
the bigger pictures,
we want to go win championships in the
UFC.
That is the whole goal.
Anything less than that,
go do something else.
Don't risk this type of lifestyle.
That is not your intent.
How many different guys you're working
with now?
I have three.
I managed three fighters in the UFC.
Pat.
Uh,
Dennis Bermudez who's fighting the
animal.
Oh boy.
The,
the most exciting fighter in the UFC
that no one talks about.
I'm confused.
You know,
when did the hundred 45 pound title
picture gets sorted out.
Nobody starts talking.
Everyone's talking about cobb and wow.
Come conor mcgregor didn't get Dennis
Bermudez for this.
A big Boston fight.
Why is he fighting Dennis seaver?
I see.
I think stylistically it's better.
They want to keep winning.
So match them up with a striker.
Who knows how to dig into.
This is a striker.
He's a striker and a wrestler.
Yeah,
but Dennis strikings fucking Dennis is
probably have mma,
wrestling and mma.
Him and pat are are right up there.
I mean Dennis is.
Dennis is a nightmare.
Who's the fucking savage?
And so exciting.
Good luck to them.
Hispanic then this is going to be
dentists can be cheeky.
I expected it to be champion and 12
months.
Well I'm just A.
He's a weird one to be cause he's like
this like a dark horse,
like he's the guy that people just are
not talking about.
I just don't understand it.
I mean I think there's a legitimate
reason when people were talking about
cub,
Swanson and Frankie Uyghur and obviously
a legitimate reason why people are
talking about conor.
Several reasons.
Charisma and skill,
you know all those.
He's got the.
In fact he's got it all.
Yeah,
but Bermudez is a fucking savage.
He's never lost in the FC except for
that one fight with Diego Brandao every
fight.
Since then he's won and he's looked
better every time he's been out there.
On top of that,
he's won five performance bonuses.
These single most exciting fighter in
the entire UFC.
So what the fuck is going on?
Sometimes it takes a while to catch on.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Well,
once they finally do catch on,
they're like,
oh yeah,
let's go back and watch his other
fights.
Like,
Oh shit.
Within six months he's going to be a
huge star in the UFC and it's actually.
I don't mind it.
I'm happy for him for it because it lets
them build.
He need.
He needed time.
He's got great coaching so he the way
down this works.
He's,
he's his home base is on Long Island
Transit,
Long Island in Miami and Belmont
kickboxing,
fantastic coaches.
They're in good training partners there.
He starts his camps out with me and they
finishes with us out here.
So what dentists need to work on was
this to cover new thing I've been doing
over the past couple years is is pacing
during a fight camp and finding an
athlete's workload,
that's
very difficult to do to find out how
much you can push someone when they
start to pull back.
Everyone's not the same,
so now when guys start camps,
they get from me a schedule of eight
weeks or however long that we have and
that schedule is broken down in the
weeks,
are color coded by intensity and also
all their workouts are plotted out now
that the plans never work out.
I'm a believer that all plans are
useless,
but the acting of planning is essential.
There's so much that you,
that you derive from that.
So they can see how their whole eight
weeks are going to look.
So Dennis had just took some time to
find his,
his pacing,
and there's two fights that he.
That he.
There were real close for them.
I think it was Matt grice and maybe
Holloway.
He was completely overtrain.
Coming into those fights,
I realized I had never seen an
overtrained athlete before.
Dennis came out and looked at went,
oh,
okay.
So it was just healthy food,
ice baths,
some soft tissue work,
some light movement stuff to get him
back.
How many days out?
I was two and a half weeks out.
Two and a half weeks ago.
He knew he was overtrained.
Oh totally.
I realize I realized I had never seen
the look on his face.
I want when I was born,
his energy to what about heart rate?
Don't am.
I don't remember if I remember.
It was hard.
It was,
but it was a more general sense and
feeling of somebody.
It's more,
you can take heart,
you could do all this stuff,
but the best you can to get is really
looking at someone getting a sense of
how they feel and that only comes with
time,
so I have to take some like a year to
really get to know an athlete and for
them to know me and for us to kind of go
through these ups and downs together.
That always happened in everyone's
career,
so that was Dennis has challenge is,
is finding his pacing during this camp
and he's really got that data and we saw
that with clay and he went there and
smash colleague that not even remotely
competitive and now he's.
He's coming up again here in a couple of
weeks and who's he fighting llamas.
Ooh,
that's a good fight.
What if I.
What are,
what card is that?
Is the Mexico City cars.
He's always just under the co main
events.
The UFC is now pushed him up to that
level.
He'll,
he'll start getting lots of attention
and he's.
He's a guy too.
That is as tough as any man.
If it was a thousand years ago.
Dennis is on the front front line with
an ax in his hand for sure.
He's legitimate tough guy and he's
smart.
He's super coachable and he listens,
which is a very rare trait in someone
who's [inaudible].
It's usually they go the other way.
Usually you win a bunch of fights and
you stopped doing everything.
Everything that you were doing
beforehand.
Dennis hasn't taken that approach.
So for this one we worked with a company
called hypoxic.
Whoa.
He's been sleeping in an altitude tent
for the past five weeks.
Simulating the elevation.
Right.
This is the highest elevation UFC ever.
7,000
plus feet.
Yeah.
So he has that to,
to help there.
He's got,
we use a normatec recovery systems to
help kind of research.
Let's use compression leg.
Uh,
yeah,
I've seen those.
Yeah.
You were telling me about that,
but I've seen it on videos.
Yeah.
We've been using those for four years
now.
It's an.
What's it do it basically,
it helps blood flow back to heart.
So when your heart squeezes that
arterial blood is under high pressure,
so it squeezes,
it goes down.
By the time it gets to your venous
system,
get returned to your heart.
It's low pressure.
So there's one way valves in your veins,
and when you walk in your muscles
squeeze it helps pump the blood back up
again.
There's a valve to get it back to your
heart.
With the NORMATEC,
they looked like these big hockey pants.
It in flight,
starting at your foot and all the way
up.
We have ones for the arms and the hips
to and they help squeeze that blood and
the lymphatic system back to your heart
so you recover quicker and it's
incredible.
You can take two,
three days if you go pump your legs for
an hour or two,
it's like a day and a half for recovery.
Really much difference.
Huge difference.
I go several years ago,
I first got one to test out.
I squatted,
I wasn't in great shape.
I squatted heavy.
I ran for an hour and did sprints.
I should have been wrecked.
I pumped for three hours watching a
movie on the TV at night,
got up the next morning.
I had no soreness in my legs.
My ass was super sore,
but it didn't.
We didn't have the hip one yet.
So it only came up to your height to
your thighs?
No,
like it really made me rethink healing.
An injury is maybe it's nothing more
than circulation issues.
Really?
Mm hmm.
What about cryotherapy?
If you guys mess around with that?
Yeah,
we do a cold plunges,
cold plunges size paths.
Have you seen those cryo chambers that
there?
I've been to one.
We tested it out.
I didn't get a whole lot out of it.
Well,
did you go to the one that got his neck
down or the one that you step into your
whole body?
It's the long as good.
I've done both.
The neck down is okay,
but the whole body one is fucking legit.
Were the one you have to put on a face
mask and your mom haven't done that.
I want to show you.
It will bring it to the place in La.
Croix healthcare in La is fucking
amazing.
250 degrees below zero and you go in for
three minutes,
he'd get out,
you get on an elliptical machine,
you warm up for like five,
10 minutes and then you go back in for
another 350 below zero and it's,
it feels like 250 below zero.
The other ones don't feel like it.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm cold down there,
but my head's not cold so it's not that.
It's just not the same,
but this one when you get out,
once you get out of it,
it's like your whole body just like
fucking electrical.
It's like things are crackling because
you know your skin is 39 degrees.
I mean you're on the verge of dying and
then what?
Go back until you have to do things like
this.
Recovery is completely overlooked in
this sport.
I think subway,
overtraining is rampant and recovery is
not nearly what it needs to.
Yeah.
That is a.
that's an issue with amateur wrestling
as well,
right?
I mean amateur wrestling,
almost all the athletes over
trained.
By the time I was 21,
I was done.
My neck was so messed up.
I was finished.
Yeah,
I mean amateur wrestling is also.
You're also 18,
19,
20,
you know,
you can do a lot of things at that age.
So here,
here's my warm up at 19.
Ready.
Let's go as a 19 year old,
warm up.
Now it doesn't work like that.
That's probably how you got your neck
fucked up to that for sure.
Yeah,
but you have to look at it.
That's why if you're going to work with
an athlete,
you have to be thinking,
okay,
we want you to go in belt and defend it
seven,
eight times.
You can make a bunch of money and not
have to work again.
He hasn't been thinking about that in
the beginning.
You can't wait until that happened and
then try to do it.
All of a sudden if you're a guy like we
had this guy fought in the UFC,
used to train with us and he'd always
come.
I did 10 rounds today and I always had
the same response,
how many runs you're fight,
he [inaudible],
I'm gonna Kinda look at them.
We never kind of never really got that
and as a result his body was done at
some other issues in his career is over,
so unless you look at the overall
overall arc of your career and how much
you're going to push your body,
you only have so much.
You only have.
You can only do so much.
It's hard to tell young Fargo,
isn't it,
that you only have so much in the
pullback?
Don't push as hard.
There's a way to tell it.
Here's,
here's a great example.
I have my first female who's just signed
to the ascent,
name's Kyle and current and she came at
terrain about a year ago and she was.
What happens?
A lot of people,
you know,
she's in the class.
No one's working with her and she
approached.
I liked her from the beginning.
There's something about I value my first
evaluation.
Mathlete is purely emotional.
I look at them,
I can usually tell if they're going to
be good this quickly.
Whole bunch of other things has to
happen.
I have to see work ethic.
We have to have a connection.
I have to be passionate about them,
they have to connect with me,
all these things have to happen,
but she had something special from the
beginning,
but I didn't spend a whole lot of time
with her and she asked me to manager and
even though there was no future for the
UFC,
didn't have a,
a,
a division in her weight class.
I found myself saying yes and kind of
started this development process with
her,
so we started really five months ago and
we threw away everything that she was
doing.
She had never really trained before,
but if you look at it,
if you pull a picture up,
she's really put together a beautiful
girl.
She's super strong,
great house,
but didn't,
didn't really know how to use all this.
Let me start from the beginning.
I said,
listen,
give,
give me four months.
Here's what we're gonna do come October.
Wait to see how good you are and here we
are in now the October,
November.
She's incredible art now.
She to debut in November,
20 seconds against Paige vanzant and we
took the same approach.
What works for you today?
What's her background?
Initially she wrestled in high school
and she's got a striking background.
He's got a beautiful striking style.
It's pretty rare to have a chick russell
in high school,
right?
Yeah.
Well she's from Hawaii.
They all seem to like the fight over
there,
but she's,
she's.
She could be a big star in the UFC,
but we took the same development
approach,
so what I need to find out was because I
got a sense that she really hadn't had.
She'd never had structured training
camps before.
She just kind of go workout and then go
fight.
So I took on two different sessions over
the summer.
I said,
okay,
well we're going to take the next three
weeks.
I'm gonna Really gonna push you.
And I found out where's her limit,
went to her body,
start pulling back.
When did emotionally she start kind of
turning off a little bit and then we.
When we did that twice,
so when it came into this fight camp,
I had a real good sense of how much I
could push her and when we should pull
her back and makes all the difference.
When you're developing an athlete,
it's just hard to find someone who's
willing to put that kind of attention to
someone's career.
It's.
There's very few people who do it.
That's why I said the talent pool and
Emma is not very big because we don't
have structured training environments
like a professional team that's got an
Ortho there at practice that has
physical therapists there.
They.
It's so it's my job to put that
together,
so we'll do.
I have a sports psychologist I work
with.
If you can,
I'm going to work with you.
I'm going to match you and we're going
to start looking at your training.
A manager should be involved with the
training manager,
should have relationships with the
coaches,
making sure that their athlete,
that that is your advocate.
I have relationships with doctors.
If someone needs a to see an orthopedic
surgeon,
we work with one of the best orthopedic
surgeons,
a two month wait to get in.
Well,
they get in within two days.
If you need a sports psychologist,
we're going to make sure that happens
for you.
If you have to see a dermatologist,
we're going to get you in immediately to
make sure that happens because the goal
is not what sponsor did you get me today
at this goal is I want you to go when I
want you to win a belt so nike calls us
not so.
Some little sponsor's going to give you
an extra 1500 bucks for this fight free
refrigerator.
Yeah,
okay,
great.
But unfortunately that's the mentality
that most fighters have that most camps
have and it's not that these trainers
don't care about their guys.
If you're running a gym,
right,
the fighters not going to bring money
into your gym,
you have to divert your attention to
running classes and all the other
things.
If you have 40 fighters in there,
you can't give all them the same
attention that they deserve,
so you really have to pick favorites and
you really have to get behind your
athlete and give them every opportunity
that they can have to win.
Do you foresee perhaps developing a team
of people under you that do similar
things so you can broaden your approach
and pick more athletes?
Or do you think that the talent pool of
potential champions is so small that if
you did that,
it would almost be like a point of
diminishing returns?
I Dunno.
I mean that's hard to say.
I have a great team around me.
I've prayed for striking coaches that I
work with.
Who Do you work with?
Struggling coaches.
I'm not sure men are is.
We've worked together for a jar 12
years.
Danny Perez has done our boxing for
He got the king most started recently
with Antony hardonk in La Shit and they
all have different approaches to things
and again,
part of my job as their manager is to
help them develop relationships with
other coaches because Emma made their
camp inboxing.
You can be the guy,
right?
You can be the one guy in mma.
There's too many things that have to
happen.
So my job is to introduce people and
help them develop relationships so they
can.
I want you to have a relationship with
your striking coach and your strength
and conditioning coach and all this type
of thing.
This is how you really have a great team
of people that I work with with these
guys,
and then I kind of oversee things I've
never worked
start with her dog,
but I want to because he's got some
really unique ideas about,
uh,
Emma.
First of all,
great kickboxer and some of the best leg
kick technique ever seen in the UFC
fantastic leg kicks.
It's,
he teaches them very different.
He,
his whole style of teaching is a very
different guy,
a very unique point of view.
Yeah,
that's what I was saying.
He doesn't,
he doesn't believe in head movement.
Hit Him and um,
and Mark Della Grotta.
We're going on it when we're in Vegas.
Not aggressively just debating back and
forth because,
uh,
I don't believe in the head movement to
move.
He's like,
he has this weird philosophy about,
you know,
not taking your head off the center
line.
Like I don't know what his approach is
based on balance.
He doesn't ever want,
want you to be in a position where
you're out of balance.
Well then how do you explain the guy
like dominick Cruz,
who's all head movement and is a fucking
monster is always to do it right,
and that's why my.
My approach isn't,
does that Ryan's way?
This is the way that we're going to do
it.
My way is,
okay Joe,
here's your body type,
here's your background,
here's what you feel most comfortable
with.
Here's your natural style.
What can we do?
What feels best for you?
We can go this direction.
What?
What do you like?
This feels better.
Let's go in this direction.
So if you gotta go cubs wants news,
wild and energetic and very
unpredictable and creative in there,
you would enforce that for sure.
Yeah.
You know,
I started before he got hurt.
I started working with Goya.
We just had in the beginning and go
though Eric Pres.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
And the whole thing would go crazy.
It was crazy.
You know,
he even said,
coach,
I'm crazy and I work.
I said,
you're not.
I think he had been told he's crazy so
much.
He started to believe,
oh,
I'm crazy.
And what were like wild and won't follow
a plan and all this different.
So I was kind of expecting that of him,
but he was the complete opposite.
He was super coachable,
follow the plan and did all those
things.
So it's,
it's not only the technical side of
things,
it's helping someone understand how they
fit in,
in helping them understand themselves a
little bit better too.
So if you've only heard that you're
crazy,
well that becomes a self fulfilling
prophecy.
All of a sudden maybe you don't start
falling game plans and things like you
would've said no,
he's actually a super disciplined,
hardworking guy who needs a bit of
guidance and structure in this
particular way.
How I'd work with is totally different
than Pat Goya's,
younger Kyland's,
a 23 year old female.
I have to work with her different than
pat who's a 33 year old guys,
had,
you know,
more experience.
And she has,
does a big thing that happens with
fighters.
Um,
and it's the relationships that they
have outside of fighting,
sabotaging their fighting careers.
It's a fucking huge thing cause fighters
is incredibly emotionally involved thing
to do with your life.
There's so much involved in winning and
losing.
The highs are so high.
The lows are so low and they oftentimes
seek comfort in relationships like
girlfriends that you can't live without.
Boyfriends he can't live without and I
think that for the female fighters it's
probably even more difficult because
unless they're fighting,
like as a female fighter develops and
grows and gets to like a place where
she's perhaps challenging for a
championship unless she's dating a
similar level fighter who can kind of
relate the guy she's
dating.
A Guy I've never heard of.
A fucking woman was a fighter dating
guys,
not a fighter.
Have you heard of it?
I've never heard of it.
I never thought about that.
CAITLIN's fortunate.
Her boyfriend is a professional surfer
for now.
What do you mean?
Once she starts kicking people's asses
in the UFC,
I'm fucking moving up the ladder and
this surfer dude sitting on the
sidelines going,
I guess anything's possible,
but yet they're there to really,
really solid good people.
That's her right there.
Yeah,
she's beautiful.
She's going to be a huge star in her
chest.
Um,
it's some type of religious,
uh,
saying,
okay.
Um,
but yeah,
the,
the trouble that if you have someone
who's super talented almost all the
time,
it's not what happens in the kitchen or
in the gym.
It's their challenge.
It's everything that happens afterwards.
Yeah.
The friends that he grew up with are
still kind of fucking up and holding
them back and then it's the all the
hangar.
As soon as you get famous enough to see
all that,
you'll get phone calls from all sorts of
weird people who promise you weird
things.
Like I had a fighter,
it got pretty famous.
All of a sudden he,
this manager is calling.
I have multiple,
multiple sponsors with fortune 500
companies.
Okay.
I've got,
of course it's,
it's,
it's all bullshit,
but you'll get,
as soon as someone gets famous,
you'll have 50 people in your ear.
By the way,
there isn't a single fortune 500 company
that sponsors fighters.
I know.
Yeah.
I mean,
but been Nike's probably a fortune 500
company,
right?
Yeah.
So it was probably 90.
That's about it.
But again,
fortune 500 company with multiple,
I don't even know how to have this
conversation with you,
right?
Fortune 500,
I think it is,
right?
There's like fortune 500 and Nike's top
corporations in the world,
right?
That's what it means.
Yeah,
there you go.
So anyway,
so what happened?
So someone will get famous and all of a
sudden everyone,
you should be doing this,
why aren't you doing this?
You shouldn't be doing that.
And all of a sudden that chatter becomes
too much and people spin off.
I mean it happens.
It's more common than,
than not.
Right?
So when you start to get famous,
most likely you're going to do all the.
I like,
I liked the exam,
the port mortem post mortem of,
of someone's career and go,
okay,
here's everything you did right.
Here's all the things you did wrong.
It's shocking how many people go,
okay,
we'll do the same thing over and over
again.
Like I mentioned,
if you were selling a widget,
you're selling this and you sold 10
million of them by these sales channels
with this marketing plan and this color.
And this was your biggest one and you
sold 10 million.
Then we went,
I'm going to sell on a different shape,
a different color in a totally different
way.
I mean,
it would in a business sense,
that would be ridiculous.
But this happens all the time with
fighters.
With fighters.
Yeah.
How does that work?
Like say what if you had a fight?
Like let's,
let's look at Chris Weidman's first
fight with Anderson Silva.
Now I'm John Donahoe,
who's a brilliant guy.
Who's the trainer?
First thing Donna says,
when I go into the cage,
I said congratulations.
And he goes,
I don't like how he's getting hit with
those leg kicks.
Those,
the first thing he said.
So we've really got to work on that.
That was the first thing out of his
mouth.
So what happens in the second fight?
Weidman checks the leg kicks and breaks.
Anderson's like,
yeah,
I mean literally checked,
no leg kicks.
The first fight,
broke Anderson's leg in the second fight
with leg kicks.
But it's that kind of a trainer that
looks at you having the most insane
victory maybe ever in the middleweight
division.
You're fighting the greatest of all
time,
who?
Clowns,
people hate clowns.
You and you fucking blast him into
another dimension with a left hook and
then basketball his head off the ground.
I stepped into the cage moments later
and the first thing the trainer says is,
I don't like how he's getting hit with
all his leg kicks.
Like that's the kind of motherfucker you
want training you.
You want a guy who's not like the kids
the best ever.
He's the pest here though.
No one's got a peach.
Your kid show the best.
You know you don't want that guy.
You want the guy who's saying,
okay,
let's look at what you did right and
let's look at what,
what was horribly wrong?
It depends on the athlete,
how you approach that.
That's the thing,
right?
It's everyone's different.
Maybe with Chris Weidman,
I don't know him well.
We had lunch one time.
He's real nice guy.
I've never worked with him,
but you have to talk to everybody
differently.
Everyone is not the same.
Well,
you're a funny dude too,
because you're not a schmoozer.
You're,
you're,
you're a real no bullshit kind of guy
and some people are not good with that.
Now a lot of people aren't and that's,
well,
you've had relationships with fighters.
Were they like it a certain point in
time?
It's like,
okay,
we can't do this anymore.
And successful guys in.
All right,
well we,
we gave it a shot,
but it's just they didn't want to listen
to what you were saying and they would
like question like,
who the fuck are you,
you know,
even how to fight and that kind of Shit,
right?
It happens after big wins,
which is the odd part about it.
Like I had a guy who went to big fights,
he came in the room and show technique.
He looked the other way.
He was done.
I'm not listening to you anymore.
Wow.
Career didn't go well after that,
but this happens all the time.
But you have this.
What is that?
What do you think that is?
Um,
obviously it's ego,
but what is that where a fighter does
not want to continue to grow and can't
step outside themselves and look and
say,
well,
this is a position that I may be in and
this is some knowledge that I should
acquire.
It's very difficult to look at what
you're doing and go,
this isn't right.
I need to make these changes.
Or sometimes it's even harder to go.
Boy,
it took me a lot of work to get here.
I think it's Kinda natural.
My daughter is seven.
She's in second grade and she said
gymnast.
So let this year she just started
winning everything,
right?
She won every event in the all around in
two or three different meats and she got
a little cocky and stuff to work that
hard in the gym.
Even her coach told me,
he said,
I got this,
and then she lost and was pissed.
I mean,
good old fashioned.
My wife tried to bring her back.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Let her be angry like this.
Right.
Was,
it wasn't like a cry baby pissed.
It was like I'm pissed.
Right.
So
I think sometimes when success comes to
you,
you start to believe that you're
invincible and you see this in business
all the time.
You know,
people are successful in business and
they'll start a new business in and fail
miserably happened to me when I first
got started in business,
a successful chiropractic offices in
Australia.
That happened right away.
I was young,
26 years old and all of a sudden I tried
something new and lost everything I
couldn't lose.
I knew this,
I got this.
I made a,
you know,
I had done all these things.
Well,
and something happens in the brain.
It's very,
very difficult to keep resetting
yourself going,
okay,
today's a new day.
Here's what worked from our last one,
here's what we're going to do next.
Because often what happens to,
if someone has a big loss,
they want to change everything about
what they were doing.
Yeah,
I need to do to train part.
I knew,
coach,
you have to do this as well.
Let's think about it.
You had all this success up until this
point.
Do we need to change everything or do we
need to make a small adjustment in this
one area?
And often that's what it is,
but people forever,
the reason they can't,
they can't make the adjustment.
Pat's been really good with that.
You know,
he had a big loss for Daniel.
That was.
Those are hard for people to come back
within that sentence,
know people don't realize everything you
train.
Not many people are going to do it.
Pat Did,
which suffer for three and a half or
four years,
train every day,
go through this whole process,
not make any money.
You know,
every year,
birthday,
one year old,
he finally gets a shot and then he loses
like that.
It's very hard to come back and to his
credit,
he did that and we looked at everything.
We said,
okay,
here's a couple of areas that we need to
change.
It wasn't throwaway the playbook and we
start over again.
It was,
here's what we need to do,
and we do that for every camp.
Some people are willing to do it,
most people are not.
Which is why,
again,
we talk about is there going to be
enough talent development in this area?
It's very hard to get someone prepared
to be successful in the long time in a
cage because most guys would get signed
to the UFC,
are there for a couple of fights and
that's it.
How did you decide to dedicate your time
and your life to this?
Because this is a very tricky position
to be in because you're not the master
of your own destiny.
You are the master of creating the
opportunities for someone else to
achieve their destiny and your destiny
is essentially tied in to them,
tied into their work ethic,
their willpower.
They're focused.
They're all of the above,
their,
their athleticism,
their natural talents as well as their
intuition and those intangible factors
like the toughness that Dan has or you
know,
the,
the freak athleticism that some other
fighters have.
There's so many factors and your life.
You're very fucking smart guy,
but your life is tied in with their
success and I'll sound that smart now
doing what you do because it's working,
but how did you.
I mean,
you had a million times,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
There's always tough.
I think it's
personality.
When I finished chiropractic school,
I got a great offer and Phoenix from an
amazing doctor who was a mentor to me
and instead I with no money in my pocket
but a one way ticket to Australia ship
my hundred and 50 pound Neapolitan,
massive.
Not enough minding Americorps and teen
30 days later and went and made it work,
so I guess it's my personality.
I knew I wanted to move to another
country who's either Costa Rica or
Australia and I chose this tray because
there was an established chiropractic
association there and I had met an
Aussie girl which made them move a
little bit easier and literally bought a
one way ticket,
landed there with no money,
but it taught me a valuable lesson
because I had made this decision 18
months prior for 18 months.
Every day.
I said the same mantra to myself.
I think that the intention is so
important in your life on what you
decided to focus on.
I mean really focused on with all of
your energy.
I believe that if you're in that place
with full trust that the universe will
direct you in this,
in this direction.
Woo.
Crazy.
Sounds really crazy,
right?
So every day I said to myself,
for 18 months,
I'm going to move to Australia.
My live in the tropics.
I'm gonna.
Have my own practice.
It's going to be great.
I'm going to move to Australia and I
live in the tropics.
I said this mantra over 20 times in
Australia because of the check.
Now I just.
I looked at Australia,
I thought it was great.
It looked like a nice place.
I wanted to move to another country and
here I go and I wanted to live in the
tropics that had been to the Caribbean
at 14 and night,
sitting on Saint Croix on January 2nd
and it's 88 degrees and I'm 14 and I
couldn't understand where there were
places like this and I lived where I did
the two just didn't,
didn't add up to me.
So I decided I wanted to live in the
tropics.
Australia seemed like a good place,
so I landed there,
hated it.
The relationship was done with the girl,
I don't have enough money.
My dog is ticking down.
I got to come up with $1,500
to get them out of quarantine.
Right.
I have no.
I've never had a job before.
My only other skill was throwing people
out of a bar and now I had to go start a
business,
be it,
find some way to make this work.
Three and a half weeks later or three
days before my dogs do together
quarantine.
I owned three practices in the Sunday
islands.
If you.
They look up the Sunday that I believe
it's the power of intention,
but I heard something from somebody got
in a car,
drove up 14 hours,
met a doctor who wanted to get out of
there quick.
She sold me her practices for $5,000
that she agreed to let me pay $1,000
a month over five months.
I walked in there my first day and made
like $800.
My first day,
I'm 26 years old.
Went and got my dog,
had a quarantine and that was the.
That was my start.
Why?
But I was willing to find out about her
how this is pre google.
Well,
that's the PR.
That's.
Here's the other thing too.
What I would do is I would get
chiropractic journals at the,
um,
at the library.
It was called Los Angeles College of
Chiropractic.
And I would cold call chiropractors and
just say,
what's it like down there?
Do you know?
I would just call people.
Right.
And that's how I ended up.
So I was there for five years and I
would fly over to Japan to meet Dan and
then came back and decided that I wanted
to make.
Now the [inaudible] m I made the.
There wasn't really a way to make a
living doing this stuff.
Not much.
No,
but it was,
it's what I wanted
to do and I had some other great things
happen,
but I think you asked me why I'm willing
to do it.
I think if I really trust my gut,
my intuition that,
that I'm going to be okay.
And through the process I met Kevin
James and worked with him for a year and
got involved with some movie stuff and
created a television show that we sold
to Fox that ultimately didn't get picked
up.
But again,
all these other things started to
happen.
That was the weirdest shit over my
computer.
Just decided to start playing.
You just heard your voice mark computer.
Yeah,
that's bizarre.
It's never done that before.
I didn't have it on the page.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I wasn't even touching my computer
anyway.
Not Important.
Um,
so for me,
for me it's about really trusting that
instinct that this is going to be the
right thing to do,
even if there's not any evidence that
this is going to work out.
But you were involved with team quest,
like even pre this,
right?
I,
I created the name team quest and this
was back when?
Randy for Tony Palma in like 96.
I think Randy started in [inaudible] 97.
Yeah.
He fought and I didn't have anything to
do.
How am I?
Was his first fight in the UFC obviously
choked him.
Yeah,
I think it was 2097.
well I had known Dan and those guys from
college and kind of came up with them
and the full fighting started.
Everything kind of came from there and
every step of the way I looked at what
skills that I would need to develop to
be successful.
So initially it was all soft tissue
chiropractic stuff and then more and
more into nutrition and then I realized,
oh I really liked the training side of
things and I was only.
I've only been involved with very high
level of camps but very high level
athlete.
That's been my whole experience.
Lucky shit man.
97 may [inaudible] 1997.
Yeah.
So I was there for that.
I was there for that.
And Steve Grandfather afterwards,
Steve Graham was a guy who a lot of
people had a lot a lot of hope for
people thought that was going to be
something special.
Right.
Big,
strong,
fast athletic shoe.
But Randy just fucking pick them up and
smashed him,
dumped him on his back and just beat the
fuck out of them and then beat the shit
out of Vituro and his third man fight
the time where everybody thought that
tour was the second coming of Jesus on
the screen and said,
I think it no known weaknesses and what
they put on this.
Yeah.
That was insane.
That was a 19 year old or 20 year old
veto or whatever.
It was.
Probably 19.
Yeah.
And uh,
had gotten up to like 240 pounds by
then.
You looked like a lion.
He didn't come out of his trailer.
He was in the cage waiting.
Also.
Remember that there was.
That was the infamous.
He had a worm excuse,
right?
What do I never heard?
This designer's randy just had kind of
hanging out in the case.
There was some sort of parasitic issue
that he was thinking.
He was also training with this guy who
wind up dead.
This guy named Curtis who was a
bodybuilder that,
uh,
we would,
Eddie Bravo who's a eddie was my friend
even way back then from when we're at
John jocks and it was like a blue belt
or a purple belt.
I think he might have been even a blue
belt back then,
but,
um,
we wound up working out the gym with
this dude at the same time,
you know,
we weren't working out with him,
but vittores trainer was,
uh,
just about as purple as a guy who get
and still be a white guy.
It was the weirdest shit ever.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck he was on,
but I assume it was everything all
together at once.
And we used to call them garden hoses
because he had veins,
like fucking garden hoses on his body.
I mean,
they were just the most retarded veins
you've ever seen in your life.
And he was enormous.
He was maybe five,
10 and probably weighed 350 pounds.
Okay.
Just purple.
He would work out.
He was to a strength trainer.
He was his buddy,
trainer,
bodybuilder,
supplier of Mexicans,
steroids or whatever the fuck it was,
whatever was going on.
But vituro had gotten up to two 40 and
this is over the course of,
you know,
fucking year gained about 40 pounds of
muscle.
And it was when everybody was worried
about Mark Coleman.
Everybody was worried about the fucking
hammer because they'd seen coleman in
his prime stud wrestler who had hit that
fucking power double on you,
compress you into the cage and just beat
the piss out of people.
And everybody was thinking,
how do I keep this fucking guy off me?
And their solution was get as big as
colman and Colman was,
you know,
two 55 just just jacked the tests,
you know.
And when he fought maurice,
nobody gave him,
gave him a shot.
Everybody was like,
you know,
Maurice got no shot.
He's going to get smashed.
And I remember talking to Maurice before
the fight and before the fight I was
supposed to do this thing for a NBC
where I was,
you know,
Bob Costas used to have that show later.
Remember that show later.
And uh,
he had left and they were looking for
new hosts,
so they would do,
is have a different person who hosts it
for a week.
This is when I was on news radio and I
was hosting it for a week.
And so I was talking to Maurice and uh,
you know,
he would always call me Joseph Joseph,
we're going to do that TV thing.
Let's do that TV thing.
I was like,
yeah,
we'll do it.
I'm thinking this poor fucking guy is
going to go fight Mark Mark Coleman.
And he's like,
so calm and oblivious like he doesn't
even.
Does he realize who he's fighting?
Does he know?
He's?
Of course he knew,
you know,
I was the one that was ridiculous.
Maurice was so calm and relaxed because
he had insane cardio me.
Maurice would say slim swim lap after
lap.
I mean he was just dedicated to cardio.
That was a good big part of his training
regiment.
So his idea was just ride the storm in
the beginning and then start getting
that big fucker tired out.
Like he was the first guy to realize you
can't really be that big man.
You can't sustain that.
Matt Hume with him too,
right?
Yup.
He hadn't Matt Hume,
any had world class kickboxing skills.
Maurice was the first guy to fight in
the UFC first.
Got To fight and Emma had ligit world
championship kickboxing skills.
And remember when he fought cone and
Sylvia,
that was the first head kick.
Keto we ever saw.
A high level of fight,
especially against a Brazilian jujitsu
black belt like Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
Blackbelt was like having an iron man
suit back then.
Like,
this guy's got a Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belt baby can't be beaten.
Maurice fucking bounced this Shin Off
Kona Anz head and that was like a new
era and then fought coleman in the next
fight and uh,
just fucking dominated coleman down the
stretch and won the title.
And like one of the biggest upsets ever.
But detour was in the Mark Coleman
school detour.
I mean,
you think about veto or now looks like a
welterweight.
I mean,
now that he's off testosterone
replacement,
literally looks like he's a one 70
pounder in between camps and back then
was just fucking huge.
20 years old,
gigantic.
And Randy came in and smashed them.
Just smashed them,
just ground him out and just beat him
down.
And I remember the end of the fight him
on top of Vituro,
relentlessly pounding on him.
Boom,
boom.
And people couldn't believe it was like
Mike Tyson getting beat by buster
Douglas.
This is gabby.
I can't,
can't be really be seeing this is can't
really be happening.
Change via towards life for years after
that to Vitara long time to recover from
that fight.
I bet.
Eh,
he was never the same guy for a long
time.
Now he is,
you know,
now he's a motherfucker now.
He's probably the best ever that he's
ever been.
But still that randy fight,
that changes a lot of shit.
So you were involved back then?
I've been friends with this guy since
1992.
Were you up in Oregon with them?
No,
I would go up.
I will kind of do adults.
Jay does now.
I'll go up with randy before a couple of
weeks before his diet nutrition.
Get ready.
And you were doing it just because you
were friends?
Yeah.
And you were still a chiropractor at the
time?
This is a transitional time,
so I had moved back to the US from
Australia.
Is here for five years.
Um,
what years were you in the?
In Australia?
My [inaudible] to [inaudible] maybe
[inaudible].
I mean,
I'm sorry.
98 to 2002 or [inaudible],
something like that.
So you knew them before you knew them?
When Randy first came to the UFC for
like years,
so I knew them years before we had ever
heard of fighting or randy first saw the
UFC went.
That's crazy.
Who would ever do
that?
This is like 90.
I think I first met Randy in 1992.
Him and Dan's still had mullets.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
So this is the.
So they fought years,
years later.
These are the guys I started do
everything I do now is cut,
developed from the training sense of
these guys got me started with that from
the management sense.
It was some your managers through Kevin.
I became close with Chandra and jeff and
they kind of were graded at least
letting me see how it really,
well,
like a top notch entertainment manager,
how do they operate,
how they handled things.
So are these two really interesting
people to draw from to create this
career that I have now.
And then I have my healthcare background
on top of it,
which you know,
management is,
is client service,
customer service,
really service the person that you're
working with,
which is very similar to chiropractic.
So the mindset for me was very similar
and on top of it all I found out that I
had a real knack for marketing business
and negotiating and it took a long time
to develop.
But I ended up here.
Well Sandra and jeffers similar to your
approach to training and managing,
you know,
developing athletes and like I've been
with Jeff since I was an open micro.
Yeah.
Jeff and I have been together for I want
to sell at 23 years,
but he got me fresh.
I was just like,
I just had some potential,
you know,
and along the way as advised me,
and we,
you know,
we've made some bad turns and tried to
figure things out and made some calls,
you know,
one is,
especially when it's something as open
ended as a stand up comedy career,
like who the fuck knows
a very similar to [inaudible] in that
sense.
Yeah.
Well you never know where it's gonna go.
But there's more options for stand up
for a fight with.
It's also victory.
Yeah.
This is it.
Like you,
you got to figure out how to win,
you know,
with a standup comic because you've got
to figure out how to be funny,
but you have to.
I mean this is a lot of different ways
to be funny.
You know,
there's just a lot of different ways to
win.
Yeah.
But you,
it's like,
here's a perfect example.
There's some guys who just will not be
funny if they're following the wrong
guy.
Like if you follow a super wild high
energy guy,
let's say like Sam Kinison,
like perfect example,
like Mitch Hedberg is one of my all time
favorite Comedians,
but Mitch Hedberg is very slow paced and
had a very like a silly style.
He had to like silly,
very silly style.
You know,
I eat a piece of carefree gum half an
hour later.
I was still worried it never kicked in.
You know,
it's like something silly and funny.
But if he followed a guy like Kennedy
and it was fucking play playback,
you would probably not buy into it.
You'd be like,
yeah,
this is too different.
It's too slow paced.
It's like a band.
Say like if guns and roses went on and
then right after guns and roses,
some like ballad guy went on in the same
crowds to follow James Brown.
Perfect example.
No one wanted to follow a little
Richard.
No one wanted to follow.
I mean,
there's a lot of guys like that.
You know,
Jerry Lee Lewis famously lit the fucking
piano on fire after he played because he
didn't want to Chuck Barry to go on
after him and he said to Chuck Berry
followed that motherfucker like,
that's like a famous story.
He might have said do
the,
depending on who you ask,
but bottom line is,
you know,
there's certain guys that like,
there was a certain impact that they
would have on that fucking stage.
Guys like Chuck Berry,
Little Richard Guys like,
you know,
down the line,
there's been a lot of like James Brown
is probably the best example.
Just what the fuck and follow James
Brown,
James Brown.
I mean,
you know,
you can't,
you just can't.
It's like fucking shows over the career
trajectory.
There's,
there's no roadmap to this is it?
It's a fighter.
It's,
you know,
you have as a community,
you and your manager,
you make these decisions.
For me,
it's not even about getting.
Some aren't gonna work out,
but what you do after that,
right?
It's similar in the fact that you're
trying to develop this overall thing and
optimize who you are in how you express
it through this thing that you're doing,
this thing that you're doing in Emma,
it's obviously it's a competition,
so it's very different,
but in the sense that you have to
develop.
Conor Mcgregor's done a great job of
letting us know who he is very easy to
pick up on that and either like it or
dislike,
you know exactly who it is and it's kind
of fun.
Have to help someone develop a style and
a persona and kind of.
I hate to use the word brand when
talking about some of the.
Something that's unique about them that
they put out there.
In that sense it's similar as a
comedian,
are you Sam kinison type or you write,
you know,
how do you figure out who to be you
best?
Yeah,
and a good manager is going to help you
in that process along the way and that's
it.
It's a unique relationship.
You'll never have a relationship like
the one you have with your manager.
It's totally unique.
Yeah,
it's a very.
It's a very unique relationship if you
have a manager like you that is like
really dedicated to developing an
athlete from,
from the beginning,
from the start of their career.
It's like seeing what it is that takes
them to reach their optimum level of
performance and that changes to how you
manage someone in the beginning.
I have to manage pet differently now.
Like uh,
how I work with Caitlin and a year from
now I'll have to be different when she
wins the belt.
It'll,
you have to constantly be changing.
Kyland.
Wait,
you're going to find out a one 15.
There's a bunch of a potential weight
classes for women,
right?
I mean like right now we only got like
one 15.
Do you see the Gabby Garcia is fighting
in Paris is 135 pound woman.
Welcome to Japan,
Japan.
So she made vandelay look tiny.
Yeah.
Gabby Garcia,
if you don't know,
is a women's World Jujitsu champion who
is fucking Jack.
I mean,
Jack like Tyron Woodley jacked and she's
a woman so it's all natural hundred
percent and she's got to lose weight to
get down to two 20.
She's getting hurt.
That's her contract.
Wait,
I guess apparently it was like her.
She has to be 20 and she's finding a
woman was 135 pounds.
So like,
look at it,
look at it there with vandelay by the
way.
That's vandelay in between fights.
Vandelay fought [inaudible] 85.
He never weighed [inaudible].
Chelsea.
All it did was lift weights for that
Tuesday.
He's pumped up right there.
He's been in the waiting room and look
at her.
So he was probably two.
Oh five to 10 back then,
you know,
in between fights and she's just
enormous.
Look at her neck and face.
Totally looks like a woman to doesn't
only.
He says any extra testosterone in their
body at all.
Kidding.
Wow.
It's a fucking house.
That's not good for your clitoris.
Right?
It does not do strange things.
I've never seen a clitoris on
testosterone,
but I can't imagine that's good,
but do not have a computer.
Do not connected to the Internet.
I have never.
Like today,
this afternoon,
and I'll look it up.
I'll tell you.
I can show you right now.
You want to see it?
That's up your shell or however you want
to take this.
Much of the rest of the blue get kicked
off at ustream.
But yeah,
it grows like a penis.
Yeah.
Which makes you think like if a dude has
a little deck,
if he just takes a shit load of test
every day.
It's like a few years was Dick Rowe.
I'm sure there's.
People have got to know the answer to
that.
Someone's got to know the answer.
Yeah.
I would imagine grow a little new for
people we could call an ask for at
least.
How dare you be so conservative.
This,
um,
this is an interesting subject to
because of,
um,
what's going on now with the eliminated
completely eliminated testosterone
replacement therapy and you know,
Vittorias the whipping boy when it comes
to that because cause he had the most
spectacular results.
You look at how vituro looked when he
fought rich Franklin whom one first
round Kol.
But you look at his body and then you
look at rich Franklin when he fought
rockhold,
if our best bang when he fought Dan,
you're looking at this jacked fucking
monster with muscles on his teeth and
just ultra super confident it looks like
he can't be beat and so many people
attribute that to,
to taking testosterone.
And it's,
it's unfortunate.
But it's fascinating.
It's unfortunate because like men veto
accomplish so much.
I mean I think those,
those three fights where some of the
most impressive chaos I've ever seen him
to stop and Dan and the first round like
that,
who fucks ever done that?
Who the fuck is ever dominated Dan like
that?
Yeah.
I mean it was crazy.
Him and Dan was on testosterone at the
same time too.
You know him stopping rockhold like
that.
Him Head kicking bis bank.
Many people have mentioned that Dan and
I actually did his therapeutic use
exemption,
so I got the ball rolling with that.
And when we tested it,
and I'm sure he wouldn't mind me saying
this,
he was off the charts in the wrong
direction.
You wanted to close the numbers?
I think the scale is two 50,
two 11 [inaudible] eight.
Yeah.
Well that is higher than allister is
right now and the higher than Vittorias
right now I'm sure.
But Dan also never.
I've I know Dan's father.
Dan's dad had like a 550 pound bench
press.
His,
his little sister is a sophomore in high
school.
Could hit a golf ball 300 yards.
You look at Gross,
like when I used
to do soft tissue work I did on Dan and
Randy.
Dan was five times the effort.
He is so dense.
Yeah.
He's a weird guy.
You put your arm on his back,
you like while you're pictures with
them.
It's like taking a picture with the
tree.
Your tree.
You're not like the rest of us for sure.
So when I did that,
I also was so paranoid because I can't
be the guy to fuck up Dan Henderson's
career with a failed steroid tests
called the UFC.
I called the Invest Athletic Commission.
I dragged him down there twice a week to
get blood tests.
He didn't want to do.
I'm like,
Nah,
if my name was on this one.
Now is this testing.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but this testing we tested 200.
That was his level.
Is this in camp or is it out of camp is
just out of camp.
Yeah.
So it's not like hard training where
everything gets Jack.
No.
What made you want to test him?
I just said,
you know,
you're not like it used to be and that's
what he said.
Dennis being overtrained.
Well what did you look for it?
I don't know,
but you're just not quite right.
And 34 maybe.
Well that's 35.
There could be a natural slowing down,
but he was very,
very low and the one thing he was very
adamant because Dan never done any drugs
in his life.
He'll drink some bad light beer,
but that's about the extent of it.
Peer.
Yeah.
So he never abused anything when he was
on.
We tested him regularly so I knew you.
You checked a little bit,
comes up,
come back down again.
He was never out of a range that was off
that scale.
So if there,
if the,
if the arrangement from two 50 to 1100
he was,
we would go to a thousand in a couple
days later it drops down again.
So he,
he never abused it in that sense.
And there's a lot of other guys he would
speculate,
did it very,
very opposite thing.
They took a whole bunch of stuff.
Dan took a prescribed medication that
was really needed and never went,
but above levels that were not even high
levels for normal.
Just really,
let's just bring you up with just a
little bit so you can recover.
Yeah.
And I think that to lump him in with
someone who may be throughout their
career,
abuse it in much different ways.
It's unfair and it's unfortunate that
guys like Dan or thrown into that
category.
Um,
but even if you look at dance weight has
not changed by more than four pounds.
His physique didn't change either.
Is He in his weight?
Didn't change.
He was.
Oh,
I remember when he was 20.
I think the heaviest I ever got was 205
pounds.
And he was like 19 or 20,
working out like crazy and I don't think
he ever weighed in at 205 pounds on a
scale.
And Emma?
No,
he was always like two or three in lower
[inaudible] and 40 [inaudible].
Yeah.
So Dan,
Dan never abused Denton.
A medication that was necessarily.
Dan did not abuse steroids in any sense.
But what is the argument obviously is
should that medication be allowed?
I mean you're saying a medication that's
necessary,
but is that just your body telling you
to hang it up?
Is that your body's saying like,
Hey,
you know,
look if you want to do testosterone for
something else for life,
but if your body from the abuse of
fighting is your,
you essentially your pituitary is not
functioning properly.
That could be a big part of what's going
on and getting hit.
I get the arguments,
but you could say the same things.
If you need surgery and you.
Let's say you need insulin,
you develop type one,
type two,
type II diabetics.
Never fighting them.
I may though do that.
None of one or two.
But in general,
no.
But let's just,
if we're gonna,
if we're gonna go down this road,
right?
Say,
okay,
should you take this medication because
you have a harder with me or something
like that.
Um,
there's a whole bunch of things that go
yet we have medications for this reason.
Unfortunately the line gets blurred so
quickly.
You have a guy like Dan who was honest
about it,
who went through the channels before we
did anything,
talk to the UFC,
talk to the commission.
I had a when we wait and hit a binder of
every single had every single test done
that day.
So we were very well prepared for that
one.
So in that sense,
no,
I think that guys should absolutely be
able to.
And Dan was one of the first,
I think Dan was the first or second
therapeutic use exemption in Nevada.
And then came the controversy,
you know,
slowly necessarily what's up guys
abusing it was abuse it.
Yeah.
Slowly but surely we started seeing guys
get tested.
Nate Marquardt,
they pull them off with the fight where
they,
in their words,
dangerously high.
He had a dangerously high testosterone
count.
Mean I don't know what the number was,
but apparently it was significant enough
that a doctor advised him to not be able
to compete.
Was pretty shocking,
you know,
there were certain number,
I don't know what that number and what
are they worried about?
They're worried about his opponent or
him.
It's a good question.
Is it?
Well,
first of all,
is this ignorance,
was the guy in Pennsylvania,
was he just ignorant to testosterone
replacement?
Did he not understand that there was no
nate to mark?
Mark Doers?
No.
I'm a worry about Mark Hartz health or
was he right?
You know,
I don't know.
I'm not a doctor obviously who.
I don't know what the number was and.
But I do know that the guy literally
said this is dangerous because a
dangerous line,
unfortunately since I don't know the 50s
or 60s,
steroids have been involved with,
with sports and the higher the level of
the more stakes there are,
the more chances you're going to see
this abuse.
So in a perfect world,
no,
I think I should be able to take it.
Everyone's going to be honest.
You're not gonna,
you're not gonna go over all that stuff
and voice.
That just doesn't happen.
No.
Do you think that guy should be able to
take it just because everybody should be
able to recover at a in a sort of like a
seemingly healthy normal way and some
people are just,
they have some sort of a natural
impediment and they should be able to
overcome that natural impediment with
science?
That's the argument I guess so because
it doesn't make you better.
What makes you better as hard work,
but it allows you to work harder because
it allows you to recover better in a
sense.
Doesn't near squeezy pants,
doesn't allow you to work harder because
it was recover.
Where do you draw that line?
Right,
and unfortunately it's become such a
taboo topic right now that in reality
drugs are going to be part of every
sport from 40 years ago to is our
grandchildren's as far as we go into the
future.
It's going to happen.
Right?
Why do people take vitamin supplements?
Why do people take minerals?
Why do people take glutamine,
glutamine,
why do people take creatine?
Well,
they take all these legal supplements
because they give you a slight edge on
all of them together synergistically and
combine that edge and it gives you a
little gap.
That little gap.
We've experienced it.
I mean,
I,
there's stuff that we sell it on it
that's fucking a hundred percent legal,
but we'll give you a boost that,
that,
um,
cordyceps mushroom supplement.
Have you tried shroom tech?
Have you ever used that?
I gotta give her some of this shit is
fucking incredible for oxygen
utilization.
It gives you like an extra gear that
gives you another round.
You'll give me another round and another
burst of energy.
Totally legal and it's nutritional
thing.
It's quite some mushrooms and
[inaudible] and we know that [inaudible]
gives people a boost of energy.
We know that people have been doing b,
12 injections before wrestling matches
and all sorts of competitions for the
longest time.
Completely legal.
We booked.
They do because it's effective.
It should that be illegal.
Where do you draw the line?
If you cannot be [inaudible] can you
have a b,
12?
No,
no,
12.
Can I take a multivitamin or what the
fuck?
What are we doing here?
Like what?
Where is the line?
And I think the line's always moving at
one point in time they allow the
testosterone and now after veto or
tested at 1,475.
Yeah,
that's on it.
That's like,
oh,
that's not even a person.
You know,
that's some new thing.
I'd like to feel that.
It's like just raging with that crazy
hair cut off is at 1,475.
Just pop out of the bed in the morning
and in dance you do some prayers and
then just start fucking running hills.
Yeah,
I would love that.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I don't know if there was no
repercussions to that for sure.
I mean I want to feel that there must be
repercussions.
So.
Right.
That's the other thing too,
is I tell guys all the time,
if you're going to start messing around
with your endocrine system,
go talk to an expert.
Don't take this stuff that Tony at the
Jim gave you.
Go really go find someone who knows,
says get blood tests,
get regular work to.
Of course that falls on deaf ears most
of the time.
Yeah,
it does fall and there's a reality also
that you can only get so big naturally.
Like when you see a guy who's gained 40
pounds in a year,
your eyebrows should go look at the size
of like a defensive line of an NFL team
in 1975 and look what they weigh now.
And what do you think about,
do you think that some of them is just
genetic engineering?
You know like now I mean in the sense
that like big guys have chosen big women
and have fucked and made babies that
people are bigger now than they've ever
been.
Shoe sizes are bigger now than they were
20 years ago and also hormones in food,
they really do believe that that is
having an impact of caloric intake as
well.
So if you're eating tons calories at a
young age,
you know your body's going to go into
puberty quicker and then you just,
you secrete more growth hormone and you
get bigger.
So that's why the average foot size over
the past 20 years is bigger than it was
before.
So that plays a factor in,
but now the NFL is going to test for
growth hormone.
That's supposedly they're going to do.
I know a guy who supplied a bunch of nfl
players with stuff and he just basically
said,
yeah,
everybody is like you can't do.
You can't have a 330 pound guy running
into you and be able to get recovered
again for next week.
You just can't do it.
We,
but we want to see that the Olympics,
I want to see Olympic records being
shattered.
Well,
you get to a point,
if I'm watching a hundred meter sprint,
you really can't.
There's a physiological limit that
you're going to get to that when drugs
will help push it.
And this fence we don't like to talk
about,
but you all want to see it.
I want to see home runs.
If I watch a baseball game while I have
this ridiculous idea,
once I thought I was like,
how high can I jump?
I can jump like,
you know,
this high,
whatever it is.
I'm like,
this one I'm going to do,
I'm going to take a pencil and I'm going
to jump up as high as I can and I'm
going to scratch the wall with his
pencil scratch,
scratcher post this pencil,
but I'm just going to do it every day,
so if I just keep jumping,
I'll get better.
I'll get stronger.
If I keep jumping,
eventually I'll just jump out of the
fucking roof.
I was like,
no,
is not.
There's a point of diminishing returns.
Is there a point where you just,
you're not going to jump any higher.
It doesn't matter how much you practice.
It doesn't matter how much you work out.
There's the the load limit on your knees
and your hips and your muscles and your
tendons and ligaments.
Yeah,
well,
yeah,
I'd be jumping everyday for fucking 30
years.
I like,
goddammit,
I can't clear this one mark that I made
and it's just,
no,
it doesn't work that way.
The body has limitations.
Then there's.
I guess the flip side is,
yeah,
the format model is the greatest
example.
You know Roger Bannister,
no one can break the four minute while
he does it and then like the next year,
like 12 people do it in the next year,
25 people do it now.
There's high school kids.
He'll run under that power of belief
plays.
Is that counterbalance to this whole
argument?
Yeah.
Why do you think the NFL even wants
people to be tested for human growth
hormone?
Sure.
They don't know who the fuck is
pressuring them.
Society.
I don't know why they should go.
What?
A few games on Sunday today click hang
up the phone.
Who says that to say that we're going to
test and then they actually follow
through and tests are two different
things.
We're going to test everyone because if
I say Joe on Thursday or income test,
you went meaning today's Monday,
so you do your last shot and midnight on
Wednesday night and then you're good to
go because really the.
Even if you fail it,
I've always said this,
you feel a drug test in mma means you're
an idiot.
Well not anymore.
Now they're doing this like really
strict protocol that's like $40,000
a test in there.
That's how chill got popped.
I mean,
they're testing for EPO and human growth
hormone is always around that stuff.
I mean really the guys you do?
Yeah,
of course.
Have you seen these new tasks?
They'll spot human growth hormone three
weeks out.
New tasks apparently stopped taking it
three and a half way,
but whatever the numbers are,
you're going to have athletes who will
always find a way to get around things
into cheat.
It's always going.
It's always happened in the the WHO's
ever doing the drugs she's ever supply
and they're always one step ahead with
the testers would.
If a guy had to have a camera set up
like on a Webcam and everyday he has to
take us of a finger prick.
Like you have a home sensor machine and
you see people do it.
You take your fingerprint,
you put it on.
Like this home sensor machine sensor
recognizes your fingerprint that's
giving this blood sample.
It analyzes a sample without any input
from you whatsoever,
and their results immediately go to a
lab.
So you have to do it every day.
If you're competing now,
that'd be great.
To fake finger.
Someone fell,
right?
Yeah.
They'll figure out a way to fucking have
a big dick sat there that you can put
someone else's urine and some will come
up with a fake fingerprint.
Didn't randleman do that then use the
flight deck.
Was it him or was it someone did tom
sizemore got busted using the fake Dick
who was trying to escape from some sort
of a DNA check that in your luggage and
your pants all the time and you just
hope they don't check.
I mean,
imagine if someone that's not even a
real deck and start yanking on your desk
like,
Hey,
it is isn't real.
Dick Tsa.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah they do have.
They have rubber ducks.
Nuts.
Yeah.
I like,
I liked the,
I like the testing.
I think that's good particularly because
I have athletes that don't use any
drugs,
so I prefer to keep everything as clean
as possible.
But did you get bummed out when they
pulled the testosterone replacement?
Because if you were a guy like say you
don't handle them anymore,
but if you were handling dance career
and all of a sudden and Dan,
the guy who did it ethically and was
taking,
you know exactly what he should be
do it all by the rules and then they,
they pull it because one guy or a few
guys or whatever was abusing it.
It's a challenge for sure.
You just have to find a way,
right?
You have to adjust training.
You have to go back and go,
okay,
now we need to.
We have to rethink what we're doing and
how we're doing.
So we have to pull back on the training.
You have to do less.
Maybe shorter intensity.
Maybe we.
Maybe the camp instead of eight weeks is
six weeks.
He just changes change the strategy.
And what about is there any,
any shortcuts to recovery other than
those pants?
The squeezy things?
Is there anything else and rest.
And then the biggest thing is staying in
shape.
The one thing that randy did better than
when he was always in shape,
so whatever else never injured that you
know.
Do you know Peter Graham?
He's a kickboxer.
Here comes another one.
He's 30,
probably 37.
He's been competing at a high level for
20 years.
He's never had an injury that's causing
him to miss training or fight.
It's incredible.
When you look at athletes,
most people,
again,
we go back to,
is there ever going to be enough talent?
Well,
most people,
their bodies can't handle the stress of
training.
I can't.
My neck went at 21 or 22 herniated disc
and then all of a sudden things are done
right,
so you have to have a particular joint
structure,
bone structure,
musculature that your body can withstand
years of pounding and pounding and
pounding.
That's one thing they mentally have to
be able to stay in the game.
If you get rich and famous,
can you handle that?
Well,
that rules that most people are there,
you're going to go off the rails anyways
and then you can surround yourself with
the right people.
All these certain things have to happen
for you to achieve this level of success
and that's very difficult that those
come through and within mma may,
it's the lowest barrier for entry than
any professional sport.
You could take a guy off the street and
said,
do you want to be a pro MMA fighter?
You could go to a local promoter in
sale,
sell 40 tickets,
and he'll get you a fight.
That does happen.
It happens all the time.
Especially in those old school like
Indian casino fights these to have in
California when there was no,
they still go on.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
In California,
they still go on.
Even though it's sanctioned,
sanctioned,
they still do these sort of off brand
promotions where they have these guys
that are just fucking completely
inexperienced,
have no business being there,
so the barrier for entry is very low,
but really finding quality people,
quality athletes so you can because you
have to invest in people to.
It costs money to do this.
That's the one thing we didn't talk
about.
If you're going to have someone go,
okay,
Joe,
all of your,
all of your transactions are going to be
private training sessions so you get
exactly what you need for that day,
but that doesn't come cheap either,
so you have to really make investments
in people.
To me,
someone will come along that really
wants to start investing in developing
athletes and then brands will start
linking up to that because right now,
even with the sponsors,
uh,
things no one really knows.
Don't really wants to touch an MMA
fighter so much.
But if you look at value for the money
and the value and the exposure that
these kids get in and the platform that
the UFC is created,
there's a ton of value here that,
that most brands are not taking
advantage of.
But there's also issues like Nike was
sponsoring Jones and then Jones had that
crazy bra with cormier and then they
pull the sponsorship loss on his side.
I mean,
I don't know how much they were paying
them how to be six figures.
I don't know what it was,
but that's a.
it's also,
there's a big cache to be sponsored by
Nike,
you know,
one of the,
whatever fortune 500 companies that are
even considering maybe getting a raise
gay ready to fortune 500 company.
They might be probably and they were
handling big.
We're promoting George Saint Pierre for
awhile or sponsoring him.
So it's like there's a couple of those
like really?
Do you think it was just the brawler
there other things as well because he
hasn't done a great job on social media.
No.
So to me it's,
that's why you have to help someone
understand how they fit in,
how to craft this image.
Look at Saint Pierre.
I mean,
he said,
how long has he been around for?
Ever heard of one bit of dirt on George
Saint Pierre?
Well,
you know,
nothing that can't be a debated.
You know,
the,
the issues with his former manager,
you know,
there's a big lawsuit that was going on
where he'd left his former manager,
but I been around as far former manager
and his former manager's husband and
there was just,
there's a lot of weirdness going on
there.
That was the good,
the guy that used to call the witch
doctor,
I remember that he was rubbing on
people's chests and aligning their
shockers and all our ah,
what but for said a career like he has.
You haven't seen any weird media things.
Great Guy.
He's a legitimately great guy.
Yeah.
John is a wild motherfucker,
you know,
and as much as he would like to contain
it and have everybody think that he's
like Super Uber Professional,
one of the reasons why he's so fucking
good is because he's so wild.
That's why he's willing to throw
spinning elbows in there and do all
kinds of wild,
crazy shit and hit a jumping flying knee
on show gun two seconds into their fight
for the title.
Know he's a wild dude.
And that's the kind of guy that becomes
a champion.
I mean,
that's just the way it is.
A fine line there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And sometimes you drive drunk and a
Bentley with a bunch of strippers in
your lap.
There's just those kinds of guys.
That's,
that's Jack Johnson,
you know,
that's fucking,
that's a,
that's Jack Dempsey.
That's the wild motherfuckers and while
that's Mike Tyson in his prime wild
motherfuckers,
while motherfuckers make great fighters,
but you know,
if you're a big corporation looking to
keep a shiny image of smiling athletes
who have beautiful white teeth,
you might not,
might not want to be associated with
some dude who's going to start brawls at
a press conference,
you know,
and that's,
that's the reality of corporations
looking to align themselves with cage
fighters.
It's a challenge in this sport and
hopefully that as a sport develops and
athletes get better at dealing with the
media and crafting ways to approach and
deal with that,
then the more opportunities will come.
Yeah,
I hope so too.
You know,
and there's also people who are
concerned that Emma might have plateaued
as well.
They're concerned that like with the Fox
sports,
one deal with the UFC on Fox and the UFC
having so many cards.
I mean there's cars constantly and
there's a fight pass cards.
So there's international cards are
sometimes two different cards going on
at the same night.
There might be some sort of an
oversaturation issue or that it doesn't.
It's not special anymore where it's like
boxing.
They'll have fights every now and again,
but you know,
there's a million different promoters,
Paul Barrons promoting,
you know,
the golden boys promoting is a bunch of
different promotions that are going on
in every x amount of months.
There's a big fight every x amount of
months.
Floyd mayweather fight.
Miguel cotto,
you know Amir Khan,
like someone who has a big name and
that'll be like a headliner marquee
fights.
They suffer the same weakness that MMA
does and that forever it will be,
will be talent.
Yeah.
I mean you could have the greatest
distribution and all this,
but if you don't have a talented
marketable athlete coming up,
you don't have anything.
So that's why.
To me,
development is the area
that's most neglected in this sport and
it's.
It's the,
the foundation of the entire sport.
You have to have a guy who's gonna get
excited,
who's going to be exciting.
It's going to win fights.
Exciting ways is going to handle the
media well.
Who's going to sell pay per views?
That's,
that's everything.
Sports psychology.
Yeah.
You,
you guys work with the sports
psychology?
We do,
yeah.
We work with a really good guy out of a
cal state fullerton and works with a
bunch of Olympic swimmers and he's been
fantastic.
And do you.
I have everybody work with this guy or
is it based on a need?
Is it a.
is it something that you have like.
Well,
you address it as part of this is this
is one aspect of who you are as a
fighter
mindset and we should maximize that
mindset.
To me it's an important part of
training.
I think everyone should work with
someone on that side of things like what
does this sport psychologists do really
helps them kind of frame what's going on
in their life in a positive way or to
help them deal with the pressure and
stress of competition.
Like what do they do?
I've never sit in on those sessions.
I'm not a sports psychologist,
but don't want to know.
So personal.
It's not my,
it's not my place to be there.
Whatever,
whatever.
I can't be there for everything and I
want them to have an outlet that they
can go to to talk about if there's
stress of pressure,
they're feeling this feeling like that
he's an expert in dealing with that.
I don't if they want to bring me in or
ask me a question that I'm happy to,
but no,
I don't want to go sit in a session.
I've never seen
sat in with a sports psychologist or a
psychologist,
but I think if it can work with
professional athletes that have probably
worked with.
I thought about doing it for standup
comedy.
Yeah.
Going with a sports psychologist to work
on standup comedy.
Like I wonder if there's something,
because comics are all like lone wolves
all doing it on their own.
No one ever brings in people to help
them with anything other than.
Occasionally comics will bring another
comics as writers,
but I wonder like mindset,
that performance mindset.
It's a very important,
whether it's athletics or
athletics as a father,
a husband.
That's it.
Whatever.
Yeah,
for sure.
But you haven't done it now.
Now with this guy,
let's say he actually.
I have talked with him on a couple of
occasions about,
okay,
during the fight week,
here are some things that that you might
want to stay away from saying more
general stuff,
like what kind of stuff.
One thing he pointed out was that like,
it's a common thing to go,
how you doing?
How you doing today?
Don't do that with a fighter.
You can occasionally,
but there's kind of some built in things
here.
How am I doing?
Why hadn't thought about it?
Well my my shoulder kind of hurts.
It's like all of a sudden you start
focusing off in that direction.
That gauge I told you about where we
have negative.
That was all from him also.
I have it a close idea of negative.
I'll text it to you.
You can post it if you want.
Okay.
It's super helpful.
It's actually,
I think it's my.
It's my screensaver gauge.
Yeah,
it's really helpful.
If you look,
I'll do it when we're done.
Yes or anything and I found this in
Chiropractic to.
I learned this.
If I go back,
I walked onto.
I wrestled my senior year in high
school,
separate my ac joints every half a year
in high school and then walked on to
Arizona state who at the time,
two years prior,
were the national champions of the team.
They took third the year before the son.
His kids were there,
so we're always Olympia.
It was as tough as a wrestling room
could get and I had half a year of high
school wrestling and I went in there and
got smashed for four months and then at
the end of four months I could kind of
keep up and survive,
but my mindset the whole time wasn't,
I'm coming here and when my mindset was
I can hang with these guys and eight
months later I would have a four three
match with a returning all American,
but I never got a five for match and
beat him because the mindset wasn't
that.
The mindset was,
I can hang with these guys.
You have to be able to create a mindset.
We're going to go in there.
I'm going to dominate this guy in every
single way,
every second of this fight,
and that is a whole different mindset
that you have to develop.
Fast forward to my chiropractic years,
I saw this happen all the time.
I saw that people who had long standing
musculoskeletal injuries,
there was always an emotional component
to it.
Sometimes it was 99% woman came to see
me and she was on some medication I'd
never heard of.
I said,
well,
what is this for?
And she goes,
well,
I have.
I'm epileptic.
I have seizures.
I said,
oh,
okay.
Well tell me about them.
And I don't know why.
Something just didn't feel right about
it.
So the more she talks,
the more questions I ask,
when did they happen?
She finally tells me,
well,
they happen whenever I see a frog,
which for you and I living in California
is not that big of a deal,
but she lived in north Queensland,
Australia.
She'd open her door and there'd be 10
green tree frogs right there.
So somewhere along the line,
her brain,
she had a fear of frogs that linked up
to this huge emotional response.
Green tree frogs poisonous or something.
They weren't just a green frog there and
her body would go into such a state that
she would have a seizure.
Frogs a rock.
She had this frog phobe so bad.
Sounds crazy,
right?
But this was her life if you think about
it.
So she couldn't go to barbecues,
which was in that part of the country
was popular.
She couldn't go outside a whole lot.
She lives in the top.
I mean it affected her whole life.
So at the time I had started a reading
it when I,
when I figured out how much of an
emotional components is all these
[inaudible] scene,
200 people a week and they come in with
back pain.
He had talked to him more and it's like,
ah,
there's so much else going on.
It's not just your back pains,
the problem here,
it's the way that you're thinking and
processing information.
It's kind of the psychology aspect to
this.
So I started reading about this guy
named Milton Erickson.
Milton Erickson was the founder of
modern hypnosis,
one of the most amazing people ever,
and he would do speeches with 3000
people in hypnotize a whole room,
and I always felt this connection with
Milton Erickson.
He had the same birthday that I did.
He lived in Providence and Phoenix where
I lived,
and so there was these strategy books on
on how Milton Erickson would do this and
within this.
That kind of led me to doing some
reading with Tony Robbins who had,
who had started with a system called
neuro linguistics programming that was
kind of founded a lot of the work that
Milton Erickson had done.
Within all of this,
there's a strategy for helping someone
break phobias.
So here I am,
26 years old,
completely intense,
and this woman comes to see me for the
seizures,
this back pain and finds that she has
seizures.
So I do this process with her.
It's kind of like this imagination thing
and you basically,
you break this neurological pattern that
happens.
I said,
you're going to go home today and you're
going to pick up a frog.
What?
And I get a call an hour later,
I get called on I or she picks up.
I said,
hello?
She goes,
Dr.
Parsons.
Yes.
I'm holding a frog.
No,
she goes,
I can't pick them up.
I said,
where are you right now?
Because I'm right in front of him.
I said,
how close?
She says,
two feet.
I said,
okay,
you'll pick them up tomorrow.
And I hung the phone.
Right.
So this is some Miyagi shit now.
Well,
it's not actually.
If you.
If you learn these patterns of,
of how you learn how to break someone's
pattern,
you can create a whole different set of
behavior right now.
What does this learning of how to break
these patterns essentially based on what
is it based on trial and error?
Is it based on hard science?
It's not my truck.
Well,
these are soft sciences,
right?
Psychology is a soft science.
You can't measure it in that sense.
But in this woman's case,
three days later,
she changed her whole life.
She say she,
she's now creating little,
little she'd put water at for them.
It changed her whole life.
And you know who her husband wants to
kill me.
Oh my God.
This his wife was no longer this meek,
fearful woman named more.
She got her voice back her.
So the husband was a mad at you.
Curve.
Husband was furious with me because his
wife was gone.
So you,
you,
you break this one pattern.
One area effected everything else in her
life.
Her mother in law came to see me and
said,
don't do that Voodoo on me.
I lost like five patients in a bunch of
money over this because you make a
change in someone's life in this sense
that it changes the whole direction of
other,
other parts of their lives.
And it all comes from these whatever
type of pattern that we're running in
our head here.
So me,
I go back to wrestling.
My pattern was I can hang with these
guys and I achieve that.
You work with a sports psychologist if
you.
If you get a mental break,
I'd imagine Anderson will probably talk
to someone for breaking his leg like
that.
I believe he is.
Yeah.
You have to learn how to process and
deal with these things and for me it's
so important not just in fighting,
fighting sick,
this extreme kind of way of living,
but something that everyone can benefit
from.
Yeah.
That's tough science thing though is
real tricky because a lot of the
benefits of something or a lot of the
success in doing something like that is
based on the confidence that you have in
the therapy.
Like if you believe that you can change,
you believe it can help you at work,
but if you'll like this shit ain't going
to work.
Go ahead.
Try it.
See it didn't work.
You know that stuff doesn't work.
Yeah.
You can have that attitude.
St People could go into the same office
and deal with the same counselor and
have a similar issue and the depending
upon their confidence in that type of
therapy.
A lot of it is based on the belief in
change.
Same thing with coaching,
right?
Yeah.
I could have two athletes.
You can
do the all the same stuff.
One will believe it and this has
happened.
One doesn't.
One will succeed,
the other won't have to go somewhere
else,
but I think you can change this.
I went to this for years.
He sends his mother a skydiving
instructor and I always see,
come on,
let's go skydiving.
And I made up some bullshit excuse about
how I didn't want to go skydiving,
but in the back of my head it kind of
bothered me.
So I had this skydiving fear linked up.
So as soon as I kind of learn how to
take control and direct my own mind,
I decided I'm going to go skydiving.
This is in Australia and I go down
there.
I said,
okay,
I want to do.
It's a tandem jump.
He's attached to my back.
We'd go up in the.
I watched him,
I watched them pack the shoot.
We go up in the airplane.
It's over the Sunday island,
73 tropical islands.
It's beautiful.
I hire a camera man.
I don't have an ounce of fear whatsoever
in my body.
Right?
At the time I couldn't have felt better
and my job really is just when he taps
me,
my job is to arch back because he has
the shoot,
so he tapped me.
I archbeck we pull the shooting.
At that moment I knew something was
wrong.
God,
I don't know how I knew something was
wrong and then I'm looking down and he
yells in my ear for words I'll never
forget we're having a malfunction.
And at that point everything stopped.
And I remember looking down in the
first,
this is what came to my head.
No motion as calm as can be.
This is the first time in my life I've
ever been completely committed to
something.
That's the thought I had.
So I look,
you know,
chute opens up again.
We dropped like a sack of potatoes.
I didn't realize that,
you know,
cause the shoot had folded over on
itself.
So it had slowed us down some but not
nearly.
Now we're going to die if we tried to
land with that shoot.
So he cuts it.
When you drop really fast again,
then he opens the reserve chute.
So at this point it doesn't say anything
to me,
and I asked him,
I go,
hey,
now he's on my back,
right?
Are we going to be okay?
And he goes,
yeah,
we're,
we're going to be okay.
I said,
man,
I need more certainty in your voice
right now,
but he goes,
we're going to be alright.
I go,
you tell me that again.
He goes,
we're going to be our,
so we're going to be all right.
Tell me one more time.
And then we landed and it was,
it's on youtube somewhere.
I actually posted a young Ryan jumping
out of a plane,
but it didn't make me nervous.
Just sitting here listening to this.
But again,
I think when you talk about emotional
management,
I think that this is a skill that you
can learn,
that you can under very,
very stressful and high pressure
situations that is a learned skill that
you can deal with and being able to work
on that stuff personally,
to help other people through it and to
have experiences like that.
You find yourself in other circumstances
where all of a sudden you're under
stress and you can perform,
and that's what the masters do when when
all the pressure's on,
everything's on the line right now,
are you going to step up and perform or
not,
and I think that to ignore that
component for an MMA fighter who's
getting in their underwear and fighting
for their lunch money,
that you absolutely need to spend time
and
effort developing that side of yourself
and you should have people surrounding
you who can help you develop that
confidence because it does not happen in
a vacuum.
It's different for every person because
every person's going to have different
issues,
different things that they fear
different obstacles to overcome.
For some fighters it might have been
getting subbed for other fighters.
It might have been being code before,
and that fear of committing and getting
caught.
You have k,
you have to have my kids have.
Each one is different,
very different.
So your.
You're challenging the father is to find
out ways that you can get.
It's all about leadership,
right?
Yeah,
and for me leadership is about influence
and it's about service,
so if you find out what these people
really need and then you can help
influence them in that direction,
then people are going to rise to the
levels that they never dreamed of and to
me that if you're in a position of
leadership that has to be your focus.
That's where it's really difficult to be
a manager.
It's gotta be difficult to a.
especially because you're.
You're,
you're professional.
Yeah.
Your profession relies on other people
putting all these pieces together.
You helping them,
but God it all.
Ultimately,
once that cage door shuts,
you can't do a goddamn thing.
You have to sit there and watch the work
and hope that it all took.
That's jeff and Shandor's life,
right?
Sort of.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They do something.
What'd you do?
A comedy special on that too long ago,
so they have to sit there and go,
shit,
I hope all this is going to work out.
Joe's on stage,
so I'm confident in them,
but that's the job.
Yeah,
it's tricky.
It's a tricky gehrig.
I'm too much of a control freak.
I don't think I'd be real good at that.
Well that the mindset that you have is
someone on the talent side of the
equation is totally different than
someone on the management side,
so hopefully you understand where they
come from,
the challenge that happened in their
life.
You try to be better at that and they
have empathy and understand the pressure
that comes from being talent and being
the one out there with the spotlight on
them and they.
They adjust their approach for that.
Yeah,
it's a when it all comes together,
I mean it's magical.
It's magical,
you know,
but it's so hard.
It's unbelievably hard to find the right
manager,
the right athlete,
the right training environment,
the right training partners,
the right scenario in life.
And then the other stuff that we talked
about,
the right girlfriend,
the right wife,
right boyfriend,
the right,
whatever the fuck it is.
The,
the,
the support system that you have at
home.
You mean how many fighters have you seen
go off the rails because their
girlfriend breaks up with them or their
girlfriend will fucking demand attention
right before a fight and cause fucking
girlfriend and a fighter.
I managed steal his fight shorts,
mouthpiece and cup two days before the
fight.
Refuse to give them back for two days
because she wanted attention.
Yeah.
But who gets to deal with that?
You.
Yeah.
So what'd you do?
The longer story.
Long story would have to check me for a
microphone.
All these crazy things start to happen.
Yeah,
of course he has the pressure pressure
shows,
cracks.
You know,
everything is nice and easy.
As long as the water pressure's really
relaxed and simple and nice to trick a
little creek,
but when it's all fucking river,
that leads up to Niagara Falls.
Boy,
does that expose
the cracks?
I've seen that.
I've had people in corners.
I've been fortunate to be involved this
the stages of athlete development from
the beginning.
You just got here too.
Oh,
you're a world champion.
Very different.
And you have to know if you're on the
management side of things and training,
you have to know how each of those
stages are different because you can
spin off the rails at any moment.
But I've seen people crack on the corner
before it took.
It took me five or six years of being in
corners before I was really like right
now.
And I sit in the corner.
I'm not at all emotional.
I see things super clear.
I see.
But that took years to develop your
would imagine.
Imagine being unbelievably difficult
thing to wrap your head around.
I'm sure it's similar to you calling
fights,
right?
The first couple,
maybe a year or two.
You do it.
It's.
Yeah.
I was worried about everything that came
out of my mouth and the fuck I was
saying like talking too much.
Am I talking too little?
Am I being an idiot?
You know,
this is a lot,
but if you're the guy in the mic putting
yourself out there,
there's gonna be a whole bunch of people
hate everything that you say.
And there'll be some that like it.
And yeah,
that's also.
But I a lot of
different things like that,
so I'm used to that,
like most of my life involves doing
things live that other people are going
to hear.
Yeah.
Like stand up podcasting and you know,
doing the UFC commentary are all live
things that other people are going to
hear.
Yeah.
So you get used to that.
And so you got to be super honest about
yourself.
You gotta be super honest about how you
would listen to yourself.
Like I would find me annoying sometimes.
I have to know when I would find me
annoying.
Some people don't want to do that.
Like I have friends that are comics that
won't listen to the recordings or God.
Hey listening.
I go,
listen,
I don't like listening to me either.
I fucking hate everything I do.
Let me tell you this right now.
Everything I fucking do,
I mean they'll be like,
I sat down with my friend already the
other day,
our issue fear.
He does his podcast called skeptic tank.
And one of the things that he's been
doing lately is going over,
um,
comedy records like that you did in the
past.
Like the play it for you and like what
was this bit based on what we think and
here,
what do you think when you hear this
bit?
And like,
uh,
we did like one of my favorite all time
cds was shiny,
happy Jihad and every,
you know,
second or third bit.
I really said like,
that's a good,
I love that bit.
That's a great band.
But the other ones were like,
oh,
this fucking back or cut that out and
shorten this,
Trim that and add it to this or I don't
like how I said that.
Or just like,
the cit tries,
you're fucking crazy,
but if it doesn't drive you crazy,
you're
not paying attention.
Well that's sort of sports psychologists
will to too.
They'll sit down and they'll watch you
go.
What were you thinking here?
When Ryan came up to you in the cage and
he said this to you,
what were you thinking there?
And they've told me to Ryan,
we in the cage,
I saw you do this.
They'll say those things to me,
but the athletes have to go through.
Well,
when you went out there,
where was your focus when you're doing?
We'd use this by called an air assault
bike.
That's like a.
it's like a Schwinn airdyne bike on
steroids and things.
Amazing.
What's it called?
It's called an era assault air bike or
air assault bike.
It's,
it's the same principle of a,
a Schwinn airdyne bike,
but it's built like a tank.
I mean,
it's amazing and it's,
it's the worst horror.
It's just terrible to be on that thing.
But salt air bike.
So yeah.
So we use Arrow Dong because I get on
that different.
It's just,
it's an Airdyne bike,
but the way it's geared,
it's that thing is horrible and this is
what we use for our conditioning now
because there's no stress in your body.
And Dennis actually has been using the
hypoxic,
who's got a mask on his face simulating
9,000
feet and he gets on and spring thing
three five minute rounds.
So these are these better than like
elliptical machines.
It's a whole different animal.
Really?
Yeah.
If I could put you in 20 seconds,
you can be wishing that your about me.
Let's do it in about 10 seconds,
10 seconds.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
So anyways,
um,
we put people on this,
you know,
Dan,
I'm Caitlyn,
does this dentists use it,
pat uses it and then it becomes a mind
because you're doing the work that
doesn't move.
You have to move it and there's a gauge.
We record all your numbers for every
sprint.
So we know at the beginning of camp
where there's numbers look like to the
end of the camp.
So what do you do when you have them do
like 30 seconds to do style sprints.
So what is to explain the Tabata
protocol for people who don't know what
it is,
20 seconds of work followed by 10
seconds of rest and we start out there.
Traditionally we're four minutes and so
we start at the beginning of the camp,
maybe once a week,
one round to four minutes and we up it
to two rounds and we go to five minutes
to simulate the rounds in a fight.
But we have all the data and I'm big on
data and numbers.
I want to see are we doing what's
working right?
Working heart rate preimposed I,
there's one thing we don't do,
that's probably the next thing,
but right now we don't,
we measure the watts on the bike so I
know their output as they're going.
Um,
so as far as the sports psychology side
of things that are.
But if that aerosol bike is so horrible
that you want to quit,
I mean it just feels terrible.
So it's one other way that we constantly
find ways to help help these guys keep
focus and push through and their bodies
opinion about hard to do that.
That thing is horrible.
Called called it Satan's tryst.
Well this looks like a regular airdyne
bike,
but it looks pretty goddamn sturdy for
something you can't Pat Pat.
Well,
Rebecca,
a Schwinn airdyne bike.
They're not strong enough to powerful
that.
That bike right there.
You'll beat the fuck out of it.
Oh yeah.
A cholesterol fitness.
I one.
Those are the same guys.
It's sold me that reverse hyper.
I
might have to pick one of these fuckers
up.
It's horrible.
I'm scared,
but I might have to get it.
What about rowing?
I think the main thing with cardio and
I,
this is something new I just learned
from Andy Galpin who's a phd,
he's the,
he's the guy who did the study on the
radius reps and he came back from a
conference to the latest data with
cardio stuff and heart health is if
you're doing,
you know,
go for a walk or you do your little
easy,
30 minutes of Cardio,
you're not getting a cardiovascular
benefit from that.
You have to get so you're that your
heart rate is getting up so hard and so
high that you're better off doing these
high intensity sprint type workouts for
overall heart health.
Yeah.
When you start talking crazy cardio or
start going,
yeah,
I'm going to preparing,
preparing,
like that type of stuff.
I like pushing myself.
I'm a big fan in getting to this hiccup
on.
I know there's one right there,
so this dude is doing sprints on it.
That probably doesn't do it justice
because he's opposed to say it.
No,
no,
it doesn't do us justice.
Why that thing is,
that bike is horrible.
It breaks everybody.
You can't beat it.
Yeah.
No,
it's impossible.
So you have this opportunity.
This is the best machine for cardio flow
for shore.
Really?
Yeah,
because because there's no stress in
your body.
You're getting upper,
mid.
I'm pushing them out of the political
machines are key code and elliptical
pretty hard.
I bet you if you sprinted as hard as you
could on elliptical for 30 seconds or as
hard as you could on that for 30
seconds,
it wouldn't even be in the same boat.
Really?
Yeah.
I use a elliptical machine the way I
would do it for the most part,
don't follow to the bottom,
but I probably should.
I would just do 30 hard,
30 hard,
30 off need to buy sometimes just if
just to keep it fresh with a 30,
30,
[inaudible] heart as you can go for
eight minutes.
There's all sorts of ways that you can
do it,
but like I've had friends that like say
like,
Oh,
I'm staying in a hotel.
Nobody fucking wait to hear.
I can't get a workout in.
I be like,
Oh,
you didn't get to work on it then come
do this.
This is what I do.
Yeah.
I'll do it at a hotel room,
a hotel gym.
What's just have nothing but an
elliptical machine.
I'll just crank that bitch.
What does it go up to?
17.
Okay.
This is what you do.
You do 10 minutes at five,
you know,
you start getting everything lubed up
and then here we go.
Crank that fucker up to seven.
So you're,
you're huffing and puffing at the end.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's where all the benefit company
always comes from.
So I could just steady jog.
Nothing.
Yeah.
You're not going to get like now doctor
gallon is telling me that when people.
Now that protocols for after heart
attacks is that you get that heart rate
up as quick as possible.
You get it moving again after a heart
attack.
Yeah.
Again,
that's just a quick,
quick conversation we had.
That's not an expertise of mine.
He'd probably be a better person to ask,
but um,
yeah,
it,
it changed.
You have guys who sprint a lot,
right?
And all of a sudden you start to develop
a knee problems,
hip problems for it.
Jump on that aerosol bike.
You're going to get all the cardio that
you need.
Well,
pat does a lot of mountain biking too,
doesn't he?
He does,
yeah.
He's a.
that's a.
that's a fucking hard workout.
Good hills on.
On.
His favorite part is the climb.
Yeah.
He's just fucking psycho.
Yeah,
he loves.
You should see the numbers.
He puts it.
I sent the numbers to the Aerosol.
I hear the numbers.
Exactly.
God,
I can't believe anyone does numbers like
this.
Like what kind of numbers on what?
It wouldn't mean anything to you unless
you got an untried it,
but he'll hit over [inaudible] watson a
sprint with that thing and for me to get
up to 1000 as hard or 1200.
So it's a matter of how much effort is
putting out.
It's all effort because it's air.
The air pumps the fan,
like the fan is pumping air in the air.
It's basically a fan kind of scoops on
it,
so it's hard.
As you're gonna move that thing.
That's the work you're going to get.
The harder you push it,
the more resistance you get because the
more air it's pushing.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
I love it.
Yeah.
I'm ordering one right now.
Add to cart,
click.
All right.
Um,
do you think that there's other things
that could be developed that could maybe
be more effective for mma?
Like you liked it.
I remember.
I think when you see this trend within,
especially this,
this for me,
the strength and conditioning guys are
the most dangerous people in and in a
fighter's camp because they can hurt
them.
They can hurt them.
They had these weird egos.
No one can do my work yet.
I broke this guy,
that type of thing.
The other problem that the fighters run
into is they go to gym a for their box
and they do their emma here.
They could hear for Jujitsu.
They go here for strength and
conditioning and no one's talking to
each other because overtrain is a funny
thing.
You can't really see it sometimes until
it's too late.
So I want to know now if,
if we had a hard day Monday and Tuesday
and pat and Katelyn are scheduled to go
work with Mel on Wednesday,
why let Michelle know,
hey,
they're pretty fresh this week.
Push him here.
Oh,
Kaylin was dropping your left hand work
on this.
Oh,
pat's doing this.
you can push this and they need an easy
light day.
Mentally they're spent.
Right.
So Mel knows that with their strength
and conditioning coach,
she knows,
okay,
I let her know we need to pull back or
listen,
let's let's push right now.
So the strength and conditioning as
they're dangerous and sometimes they set
up training scenarios,
trained to Mimic Emma.
In my opinion,
it's not the right way to go.
If in the strength room we're trying to
get strong,
right,
or if doing speed work,
we're trying to get fast.
The pride,
probably the best way to do that is to
squat,
do some cleans to get overall strength.
You don't have to put me in an Ma
position to try to be strong there.
I already spent five workouts this week
doing.
Amen.
Well,
you were telling me before we started
this podcast,
so you started really incorporating a
lot of Olympic Olympic lift.
Olympic lift.
Yeah.
And that it's actually helped your joint
pain.
Pat Pat now is shut both of us.
No shoulder pain,
knee pain,
no back pain.
We do a lot of clean squatting.
Feels amazing.
What do you think is why?
Why is that eliminating pain?
I think because I think it strengthens
your overall body in a different way.
If you're doing more kind of single
plant type exercise.
If I'm
doing a curl or subdue him a particular
thing,
there's a lot of stress that happens on
the joint there.
If you do something like a clean,
it's an explosive motion.
You're jumping,
you're using your whole body from
shoulders,
you're pulling.
It's very low.
Oddly enough,
it's a very low stress type of movement
that that enables you to get super
strong without taxing your joints.
It's a weird movement where everything's
just super technical explosion,
but that's the whole thing.
If if I'm there to get stronger,
more explosive.
If you're running me through a five,
a 25 minute circuit where I'm just kind
of crossfit style as hard and fast as I
can go.
We already did that in the inspiring.
We already did that.
We've done that.
What do we again,
why are we doing what we're doing?
Well,
the why is we need to develop more
explicit hip strength.
Caitlin had super strong hips but didn't
have any idea how to activate them.
In my situation I tried all these
different things and what helped get her
there was a cleans.
What about hard sparring?
What do you,
what do you,
what are your thoughts on.
There's a lot of fighters that bang it
out two,
three days a week and other people say
once a week is plenty good.
Not only that,
you probably shouldn't spar up until
like the last few weeks of camp.
I think less is better.
I think you first have to.
Like when pat first came out to train
with us,
there's a guy at king's mma.
He used to train there who was 300
pounds and for 200 minutes for me for
two minutes was the toughest guy in the
world.
He would do flying knees and head key
was amazing.
For two minutes.
For two.
After that he's talking about pounds.
That's a lot of fucking gas.
You need to pump too.
Yeah,
so I put them in there with patony lands
at three punch combination and then he
kicks him in the head and they all ended
up standing next to Rafael Cordeiro and
Patrick sponsee turns and goes around.
There's a right hand down the middle,
double exit into the ground,
and Raphael turns to me.
He goes,
I put my stamp on them.
Right?
Because if you're going to do this,
if you.
If you say,
I really want to be a cage fighter,
we got to figure out what's going to
happen when someone hits you really
hard.
Have you hit me really hard,
I'm probably going to go hide since I
got somewhere to be and it's not here,
right?
So you have to figure that out.
Once you know that a guy or a girl has
those natural fighter tendencies,
you don't have to keep finding that out
three times a week.
If you're going to go fight for 15
minutes,
then we're going to do once a week.
We'll spar for 15 minutes,
three,
five minute rounds.
I got that shield train was Saint Pierre
not too long ago in st peers at the same
thing.
If I'm fighting for five rounds,
I'll spar for five rounds.
Why take that guy I told you about
before?
He would do these 10 round battles.
He did that for years and all of a
sudden,
well,
fighter a has 200 rounds and you have
2000 rounds on you.
You only have a limited amount that your
body's gonna withstand before things
start going wrong.
What about light sparring?
Technical sparring.
I think it's good as long as it's not
slow.
The problem,
a tactical sparring is that they play
this lowe's lazy slow game.
I think having control is really
important.
We're switching up.
We're doing two more studies now.
Kind of back to these gloves.
Figuring out if I'm sparring,
if I'm fighting in an MMA fight,
I have little gloves on.
If I do all my sparring and 16 ounce
gloves visually,
I'm standing behind 32 ounce of
material.
It looks and feels different.
It's much bigger,
much easier to protect yourself with
those k one style guys that put.
They put the earmuffs on medium,
they put their gloves up next to their
ear,
and that's the style of defense they
use.
They go into this shell does not work in
an MMA because punches go around those
gloves around them so your defense
changes.
There's more I can throw a bad punch
with a 16 ounce gloves on that I can't
get away with in a four ounce gloves or
bare knuckled or bare knuckle did.
The whole strategy is different,
so if you spend all your time hitting
mitts with big gloves on sparring with
big gloves on,
when you get into a cage,
something's going to going to be off.
Those things.
You could hit mits as hard as you can.
The hardest pair of Mitts with those
things,
you're not going to have any hand pain
with them.
What we're exploring next,
we're doing two studies.
Next first is what part does grip
strength play in punching power and the
next one is what's safer?
Are these gloves safer than 16 ounce
gloves or a 16 ounce gloves?
Safer?
Because if you look at the amount of
padding,
a 16 ounce gloves doesn't have any more
padding this way.
We also have this bar,
this foam pad built in there,
so it spreads the area out over a wide
area,
making it safer.
The wider the area that an impact Lens,
a safer it's gonna be for you.
So it does that.
A lot of a 16 ounce gloves in the thumb.
It's in the back portion of.
It's in the risks that we are.
It doesn't have any idea.
I went to Nova and yeah,
once and I was shocked to see them all
sparring pretty hard with little gloves
on and I look at how accurate joe say
I'll do is with this punches.
To me,
this will be a game changer in how guys
are training and preparing for Emma.
Emma,
I think you should be sparring and this.
I think you should be hitting mitts in
them as much as you can do in a glove
that's going to simulate your
competition.
The better off you're going to be.
And I have a theory that we haven't
tested yet.
These are actually safer than than
boxing gloves.
Spar,
we're gonna.
Find out because there's less mass
coming at you.
If you look at the quiz,
a physics equation,
the force of something equals the mass.
How big it is times acceleration or how
fast it's moving.
This is smaller mass,
so if it's moving the same speed as the
16 ounce glove,
the force will be less because it's less
mass coming at you.
The quick two questions arise,
one,
because it's smaller,
can you punch faster?
And the second is,
um,
pressure.
How much of the impact areas landing
this bar spreads the pressure out over a
wider area.
It's going to make punching safer,
but again,
we're going to go test this in the lab.
We're going to find no one's ever done
that.
Everyone is everyone who's ever started
glove company called the same companies
in Pakistan or China and they did a
glove and they put a fancy logo on it
and they said,
ah,
here we go.
This is the first time in the history of
combat sports.
Anyone's ever taken an idea and went,
hey,
I think this works.
Let's go.
To a real sport science lab at a real
university,
do a real study and get real results and
see if we're right and let's calculate
all the different numbers and does find
finding larger
people,
smaller people,
women,
men,
guys like Carwyn with big,
giant hands,
which is always a a big factor.
Like George Foreman's hands,
George Foreman's hands,
remember equal Hams,
Hams,
same thing.
Then that's a massive thing,
right?
Having that,
it's like the difference between having
a carpenter's finish hammer and having a
sledge hammer.
This amount of mass.
Like you'd look at car wins hands.
Like I shook hands with Corwin's.
It's like shaking hands with a laptop.
I mean this is this big giant thing that
grips ahold of your fucking hand and
that's why when carwyn would hit people,
like when he hit Gonzaga,
he knocked out Gonzaga.
I mean he hit Gonzaga with like a sixth
sense punch that just shut the lights
out and it's because he's just got so
much bass.
There's so much there.
There's so there's just a different sort
of weapon.
Yeah.
That a person who has smaller hands,
like a floyd mayweather is a guy who
really could benefit from this
technology too because he's always
breaking his hands.
Floyd's had a bunch of handbrakes.
Vito Vito.
I was like a size nine foot.
It is not have big hands or big feet.
He's not like a big bone guy.
Like a car when or like [inaudible]
Lesnar dcs is this.
Does he really?
Yeah,
because he's had and issues.
I'm like,
hey man,
try this out.
To say that he broke his hand a bunch.
So here's another thing.
We'd go back to the psychology of
trading.
If you've broken your hands seven times,
all of a sudden you're back to training
again and then you put the little gloves
on and inherently,
you know.
Yeah,
that's almost most most impressive about
detour is that the guy makes his debut
in [inaudible] 97 at UFC 12.
Here is you have see what is,
what is he fighting?
[inaudible] was going to fight for the
title.
What the fuck?
Ban Use soil.
That's insane.
16 years.
He's the only guy.
The only guy out of all those years.
Besides Dan,
but I mean he's sort of kind of
eliminated Dan from that running with
his last victory over Dan.
I mean Dan did he knock out shogun in
his subsequent fight,
but you know,
shoguns not the same anymore either.
And shogun had Dan hurt just stand so
fucking tough.
He's just so much.
Well,
so fucking for a year.
She,
I never scored a point on him.
Come on,
give me one tick that one time.
No,
I've never gotten a good position on
him.
He always had that stupid power.
Oh yeah.
People knew there's video of data.
I don't know where it is of interest.
Yelling match.
This is probably in the 19 [inaudible].
He throws a headlock on the guy in a
wrestling match and knocks the guy out
with the headlock.
That guy gets up,
takes a minute and he's so dizzy.
He falls back down again.
Didn't head locked him right in the neck
while people knew.
If you're a power guy,
you'll people will find out in the first
week of training right away.
People at team quest when.
Oh Dan,
oh boy.
You know,
right away,
but he couldn't kick that hard.
These flexible flexibility.
His hips,
hamstrings,
you know,
it's funny.
His Dad is so inflexible.
You can't really bend his fingers back.
Dan's
Kevin,
his fingers,
not his dad was always like,
I can't go.
He couldn't come to this.
If you look at Danny that dense
musculature,
there's no way you can get a guy like
that to have flexible hips.
Here's the air thing,
hips,
her anatomy to.
I go back to gymnastics,
right?
There's a.
The the location and the angle of your
hip joints will allow you to either be
flexible or not.
Same with your shoulders.
So in gymnastics they check this very
quick.
Like Orange County has probably some of
the best gymnastics in the whole country
to the last five Olympic girls were from
Orange County.
So there's.
Oh yeah,
there's super high quality gyms with
that.
And to become an Olympic gymnast,
there's so many things it has to have,
but it's like being a runway model.
You have to have this certain genetics
or no matter what you do,
you can't make it.
If your hip joints are naturally like
this and they need to be like this,
you can hear what you're doing with your
hands where people are not just the
angle.
If you look at your hips,
there's an angle that they come off of
depending on how your genetic anatomy
turned out.
If it's one way or the other.
My daughter has hips that she can do.
She could do a split on this line and
go,
oh,
she's a little girl and she's been
practicing some.
Some little girls.
Can't ever do it.
Yeah.
If your hip joints are here,
the bony anatomy won't let them come all
the way off.
Is that scientific?
Because I've been.
You can love people.
They've taken people that have that.
You can look at them.
They do show that their flexibility
flexibilities absolutely limited for
sure,
and you'll see it in shoulders too
though.
They'll say immediately,
oh,
that girl is tight.
Shoulders.
Can she get it?
The gymnast are the ones who figure it
out.
We also train gymnastics too,
so it's a fascinating sport in that
sense.
You trained gymnastics people at rain?
No,
no,
we.
We go to a gym train in gymnastics.
I've seen patent do that.
Is that because of your daughter and
your connection?
We met her.
She was Arco Art gymnastics coach.
I have an Exec at a gym called scats in
Huntington Beach.
He was my daughter's coach.
He left the gym and we just started
training with Ivan.
No shift.
So what is the benefit of gymnastic
training for something if you want to
ever want to feel weak and
uncoordinated,
come do some gymnastics with us.
I know George got really into
gymnastics.
First of all,
you get super strong in the most
functional way possible.
I mean looking at Olympic gym does.
If you want to see someone crazy,
the number one gymnast in the world or
in a female gymnast is a girl named
Simone biles.
She just won the world championship.
Again,
if you watch her floor routine,
your mouth would fall open.
She's got got King Mo musculature and
she's five foot nine is incredible as an
athlete can be to make it to that level
in gymnastics.
All these things that have to happen,
but the genetics have to be there first.
Then you have to get super,
super ballsy to do high level.
Gymnastics is a level of bravery that
most people will never really fully
flipping through the air and shit and
hoping you don't land on your feet.
It's like it's controls the girl.
Yeah.
Look at her.
Oh my God.
But what she does,
we're going to lay this.
Oh my God.
She doesn't even look real.
No,
she does.
That's insane.
Again,
Simone Biles,
she does last name [inaudible].
It's B l e s.
Oh my God.
And I think.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
These flips are insane.
She planted.
Holy Shit.
She's incredible.
This to me is the greatest athlete I've
ever seen.
Whoa.
Yeah.
If you could teach that checks.
I'm Emma.
You imagine what you would do two checks
while she was on it for nine,
so no reason ever.
Hundred,
15 pounds.
That's good.
So yeah,
the gymnastics training was w it
develops your ways.
She's probably 90 pounds for nine,
so we needed something below strawweight
for women.
That's probably a good idea anywhere.
There's a lot of women that are a
hundred pounds.
She's four nine.
And how old is she?
17.
Jesus Christ fucking flips.
That's insane.
The way she sticks it is incredible.
Yeah,
so w we started doing gymnastics because
it gives you a body centered awareness
that you can't get anywhere else and it
requires so much strength and how do you
stop?
How do you do it?
Like with the MMA training,
the first thing we had to figure out was
what can you do and what can't you do?
Oh my God.
Because when we first started going
there that we did some things and I had
a shoulder injury that it's like,
okay,
we can't do that.
You are not a young girl or young kid.
You had a shoulder injury from
gymnastics.
Yeah.
We've got so excited.
We just started to do some stuff that we
didn't know was stuff we were doing.
We tried to vault and the act of
blocking on the vault,
which we initially thought would be good
for throwing punches and snapping my
shoulder.
We're not having that.
Right.
So we do a lot of work on the parallel
bars,
a lot of work doing gymnastics as well.
I've got to get my.
Get my work.
Can you do a flip?
Oh yeah.
You can do a flip.
Like standing on the ultimate fighter.
It's on tape.
But did you not do that before you
start?
I did gymnastics as a kid.
Did you really?
First Sport was ski jumping,
seconds,
gymnastics.
Third was wrestlers sport with ski jump.
I lived in New Hampshire,
maniac.
I lived.
I lived in New Hampshire.
I started in TV.
I told my dad I want to do that.
He must have been so happy.
My little boy is going to fly through
the air and hopefully not break his
neck.
Yeah.
Wow.
So no,
I had done gymnastics.
It was always something like that'd be
cool.
The train that again.
And then through my daughter's
gymnastics we had the opportunity to do
it.
And so are you seeing the tangible
benefits with guys like pat utilizing
gymnastics training?
Are you seeing that?
Are you seeing like people.
I guess the whole thing is,
are you feeling good?
Are you doing well?
Right,
right.
And Tom Watson trains a ton of
gymnastics now to Caitlyn comes and
trains with us.
Yeah,
it's it.
You should come down and do this.
Such a fun,
amazing.
Live so fucking far away or not even
that far away.
It's just la traffic is such horse shit
you did on a Sunday or something when
family time for me most of the time.
All right.
We'll write.
We'll never do it.
But uh,
if I,
if you find a place up here to do a
private gymnasts,
you get on the parallel bars,
you just swinging dips,
you get on the rings and you.
Yeah.
Trey,
you know,
muscle ups and dips and handstands and
it's an amazing workout.
Yeah.
It seems like it would be.
I mean,
I'm big on bodyweight stuff.
I do a lot of body weight squats and I
do a lot of Chin ups and they do a lot
of things is there's no better body
weight workout than gymnastics.
No.
I would imagine that comes into play a
lot.
The number one male,
a gymnast in the world is at that gym
that that was his home gym.
He's now at like Michigan state or
something,
so we went and watched him and his
teammate workout esmail did gymnastics
right in front of you was a crazy
experience.
So I see one of them doing as a ring
routine.
If you've ever seen a top ring,
Richard,
and right now it just looks in rain.
Guards are giant to the ridiculous arms.
Yeah,
they're all huge,
right?
So he does this ring routine.
I go,
what happens if you take a month off
because I can't do any of that a month
ago,
go,
you're kidding.
He goes,
no.
So they have to continually do it,
continue to do so.
We go do gymnastics.
Whatever progress we feel that we're
making,
you would take a week,
a week.
That's all gone.
That's amazing because it's such an
unnatural thing to be swinging like a
chimp on,
on the rings.
He just have.
It's a level of strength and body
control that exists in no other sport
and it's all about this perfection in
perfect form and perfect movement.
It's fun.
Do you,
are you concerned at all to doing that?
Puts a lot of stress on the ligaments
and joints and I said,
well,
we figured out pretty quick what we can
be doing.
What we can't do in.
We just ran out of time,
dude.
We just did it three fucking hours.
A long time.
Flew by,
but fun.
Thanks for having me,
Brian Parsons.
You're a bad motherfucker.
It was good talking to brother.
I always a pleasure to do this more
often.
Let's do this and let's.
Let's keep up with progress and tell me
how fighters are doing all kinds of
shifts off.
I'll come back whenever you want.
And these gloves.
How can people get ahold of them or they
sale yet there?
You can go to radius.
[inaudible] Arias wraps,
W R A P S R a g I u s w o r a p s where
at radius wraps on twitter and we're on
facebook.
Find us.
Shoot me an email if you have any
questions and happy punching me.
Punching indeed.
And your twitter is Ryan Radius Mgmt
Ryan radius MGMT.
Thank you.
My brother talking to you tonight,
everybody that was three hours.
Yeah.